le compte-rendu analytique de la
précédente et ont été distribués il n'ya
pas d'observation le procès verbal est
adoptée sous les réserves d'usagé pas
d'observations séance adopté monsieur le
premier ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues comme
cela a été annoncé en séance hier je
vous rappelle que le port du masque est
obligatoire dans l'ensemble des salles
de réunion de circulation du sénat je
vous ai donc demandé de bien vouloir
porter un masque dans l'hémicycle bien
sûr vous pouvez l'hôte et le temps d'une
prise de parole et vous respecterez
l'ensemble des gestes barrières et je
vous rappelle nos entrées pas le couloir
en eau de l'hémicycle pour le
gouvernement parle devant de même que la
désinfection et des micros effet assurée
par les fichiers du sénat que je
remercie de leur défense mes chers
collègues les conclusions adoptées par
la conférence des présidents réunis hier
soir ont été publiées sur notre site est
l'occasion d'accueillir à nouveau le
ministre en charge des relations avec le
parlement
en absence ce pays en l'absence
d'observation je les considère comme
adopté ce premier ministre mes chers
collègues d'envoi du jour appelle les
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
elles sont retransmises en direct sur
public sénat et chacun et notamment pour
cette dernière séance de questions au
gouvernement
puisque nous aurons achevé notre session
extraordinaire à une date raisonnable
c'est-à-dire le 24 c'est à dire dix
jours quand même après une teinte
fatidique à mes yeux
chacun sera attentif au respect à la
fois de son temps et au respect c'est
encore plus important des uns et des
autres et je donne la parole à notre
collègue henri cabanel pour le groupe du
rassemblement démocratique et social
européen
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse au
ministre de l'éducation nationale de la
jeunesse et des sports
vous avez récemment annoncé le protocole
prévu pour la rentrée scolaire 2011 avec
deux hypothèses en présentiel et à
distance en fonction de l'évolution de
la pandémie
je salue l'anticipation les informations
apportées cependant de nombreuses
questions restent en suspens
tout d'abord le fond la circulaire du 10
juillet indique qu afin de garantir la
santé des élèves et des personnels le
respect des règles sanitaires essentiel
doit être assurée c'est indispensable
effectivement d'ailleurs le masque est
désormais obligatoire dans tous les
lieux clos public accueillant du public
mais comment les élèves de plus de 11
ans vont ils pouvoir rester dans une
même classe ainsi qu'un extérieur
pendant plusieurs heures avec un mars
avec masques car tout le monde sait très
bien que les distances ne pourront être
inspectés à effectif complet
allez-vous prévoir des pauses dans
certaines conditions
ce sera très compliqué notamment dans
des préfabriqués
comment va être géré la garde des
enfants plus jeunes s'il ya une mise en
place de demi groupes afin de permettre
aux parents de travailler
la méthode ensuite concernant les
conditions sanitaires
les élus ont souligné la difficulté
d'assumer ses charges supplémentaires
que ce soit financièrement ou au niveau
des équipes techniques
certains se sentent d'ailleurs très seul
combien de temps elle avance allez vous
avertir les maires du scénario choisi
alors qu'ils ont un responsabilité les
écoles primaires élémentaires et la
préparation de la rentrée
qu'avez vous prévu qu'à vous prévu
pardon pour accompagner les communes a
fortiori dans les territoires ruraux
dans les fiches techniques vous
préconisez par exemple la remise
d'équipements informatiques sur
initiatives locales
les collectivités ayant des budgets de
plus en plus contraints qu'elle est
laide prévoyez-vous idem pour le
personnel supplémentaire qui devra
déployer pour les surcharges de travail
dans les missions sanitaires
pour vous répondre la parole est
favorable la ministre déléguée chargée
des sports marachi nerfs à nous merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs et sénatrices
monsieur le sénateur henri cabanel
veuillez excuser monsieur jean michel
blanquer qui est en déplacement avec le
président de la république au sujet du
plan jeunesse la question vous poser
concerne principalement les indications
sanitaire qui seront soyez en rassurés
bien travaillé en amont avec le haut
conseil à la santé publique je voulais
vous donner néanmoins quelques
indications qui indique dans cette
circulaire et qui font l'objet de sertic
eu certes circulaire qu'a mis en place
déjà le premier ministre dès le début de
juillet cette question me permet de
remercier les maires et l'ensemble des
élus de qui ont travaillé sans relâche
aux côtés des directeurs et directrices
de l'éducation nationale et plus
largement de tous les personnels qui ont
fait en sorte sur tout le territoire
d'assurer à nos élèves
l'enseignement à distance puis le retour
à l'école ils ont répondu présent tout
au long de la crise et monsieur le
ministre de l'éducation nationale a
souligné à plusieurs reprises et exprimé
sa reconnaissance pour tous ces
personnels de l'éducation nationale
pendant cette traversée de la crise
sanitaire il est normal qu'il y ait
beaucoup de questions quant à la rentrée
et c'est pourquoi nous avons souhaité
dès le début juillet qu'au travers de la
circulaire les élèves leurs parents les
et les équipes éducatives mais aussi les
collectivités disposent d'un cadre
clairement établie pour la rentrée 2020
tous les scénarii ils sont envisagées
pour garantir la continuité des
apprentissages des élèves les besoins de
chaque élève seront précisément
identifiés au moyen d'outils
d'évaluation en début d'année et chacun
aura une réponse adaptée mise en oeuvre
aussi bien à l'école au collège et au
lycée
tous les moyens seront déployés pour
garantir la reprise d apprentissage sur
des bases solides 1.5 millions d'heures
supplémentaires seront utilisés en plus
du temps scolaire le ministère poursuit
son ambition d'élever au niveau le
niveau général des élèves sur les
savoirs fondamentaux et c'est pourquoi
l'école primaire demeure là
première des priorités l'école primaire
va bénéficier c'est inscrit dans la
circulaire de 1688 postes
supplémentaires au conclure et d'une
limitation de la taille des classes à 24
élèves notamment en section maternelle
cp et ce1
de plus faut conclure oui un apport
supplémentaire sera apportée pour les
élèves en situation de handicap avec
8000 postes supplémentaires qui seront
des gagnants merci merci
j'indique eux il faut pas parler trop
proche du micro n'y a en effet pour des
raisons sanitaires pas de filtre et donc
tenez vous à une certaine distance
ça aidera nos services à faire face je
donne la parole à notre collègue
christine pris nos pour le groupe
communiste républicain citoyen
écologique on chez lui sans doute une
des dernière intervention devant le
sénat en la remerciant pour son
engagement pour notre assemblée
je vais peut-être revenir sur ma
décision
finalement voilà président merci
beaucoup monsieur monsieur le ministre
mes chers collègues
cette question est destiné à mesurer
ministre des solidarités de la santé
alors depuis lundi le port du masque est
devenu obligatoire dans les lieux
publics clos des manades des masques
indispensable donc mais qui représente
un coût de plus de 200 euros par mois
pour une famille de quatre personnes
certes vous venez d'annoncer la
distribution de masques gratuits aux
plus précaires et aux personnes à risque
mais comment s'organisera cette
sélection par quel organisme
au bout de combien de temps et pour les
autres camps aujourd'hui l'urgence est à
la gratuité comme vous le proposez des
gens juin une résolution des groupes des
députés du groupe gdr la gratuité un
coup oui d'ailleurs supporter largement
par les collectivités
merret coût moindre qu'une surcharge des
soins en réanimation et n'en déplaise
aux propos ici ou sénat ya quelques
temps de la ministre pas nier une hache
et la gratuité n'est pas je cite un
frein à l'innovation un frein le feu en
fait c'est la perte de nos outils de
production comme par exemple ouzzine de
masques à plaintel dans mon département
fermé depuis deux ans un projet pérenne
d'une coopérative d'intérêt collectif
est menée à grasse toujours en côtes
d'armor avec l'appui de la région et du
département
voilà un levier pour assurer notre
sécurité sanitaire de proximité
pourvoyeuse d'emplois en plus
le soutiendrez vous bref monsieur le
ministre porterez-vous enfin le choix
politique de la gratuité des masques
pour tous au bénéfice de la cause de
lags de la société de nos concitoyens
notre pays en a les moyens
je veux remercier on vous répondra par
an les communistes des solidarités de la
santé monsieur verront ils avaient la
parole madame mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs madame la sénatrice pruneaux
il me revient l'immense honneur de
répondre à votre dernière intervention
si j'ai bien compris
au cours de cette séance de questions au
gouvernement j'ai répondu à une question
similaire hier à l'assemblée nationale
et le président la république a eu
l'occasion de s'exprimer hier dans une
interview télévisée pour dire qu' il n'y
aurait pas de distribution gratuite pour
tous de masques mais quand aucun pays
d'ailleurs de le faire aucun pays au
monde en aucune circonstance et qu'en
revanche il y avait une distribution qui
avait eu lieu déjà très tôt à
destination des publics fragiles des
personnes les plus précaires dès le
début alors que nous étions en train de
constituer des stocks nous assurions la
distribution à travers les associations
à travers les mairies à travers les ccas
de 5 millions de masques par semaine de
manière à protéger les personnes les
plus fragiles j'ai déjà également
annoncé hier que pour 2 millions de
français en situation de vulnérabilité
sanitaire cette fois sur prescription
des masques chirurgicaux pourraient être
remboursés
en charge totalement par l'assurance
maladie donc nous portons évidemment une
attention plus fragiles madame la
sénatrice
j'aime aussi comme vous les
mathématiques et j'entends et je lis ça
et là qu'il y aurait un coût pour une
famille de deux enfants de 220 euros par
mois j'attire votre attention sur le
fait que j'ai à coeur de porter des
masques qui ne sont pas des masques
chirurgicaux que je réserve aux
soignants mais des masques qui sont à la
fois lavables renouvelables et qui sans
doute pollue moins et même certainement
pollue moins que les masques destinés
aux soignants se masquer la coûte 1 euro
il est lavable et réutilisable jusqu'à
30 fois admettons vous utilisiez trois
masques par jour et que vous ayez besoin
30 jours de porter un masque si vous que
vous êtes 4 j'arrive un calcul qui est
plus proche des 15 euros 20 euros à la
rigueur si on inclut les week-ends que
des 220 euros
cela étant s'annonce à notre pas sa note
pas madame la sénatrice la priorité que
vous portez au fait que les plus
fragiles puissent être protégés et qui
n'est pas d'obstacle financier
croyez moi comme ministre de la sorte de
la santé mais aussi des solidarités je
fais y aurait personnellement à ce que
personne ne soit en impossibilité de
porter un masque
compte tenu d'un obstacle financier je
crois que c'est essentiel et nous
pourrons nous retrouver autour de cet
objectif
merci la parole la parole et à notre
collègue andré vallini pour le groupe
socialiste et républicain
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre des affaires étrangères une
tragédie se déroule sous les yeux du
monde entier en chine arrestations
massives et arbitraires camps
d'internement et de rééducation viols et
tortures stérilisation forcée et
avortement contraint la chine martyrise
le peuple ouïghour et peut mener jusqu'à
sa disparition
face à ce qui s'apparente déjà comme un
crime contre l'humanité une mobilisation
internationale s'esquisse avec notamment
les états unis de donald trump qui a
annoncé des sanctions à l'heure face à
cette tragédie
que dit la france et surtout que fait la
france
pour vous répondre la parole d'état jean
yves le drian ministre de l'europe des
affaires étrangères de la parole
monsieur le sénateur vallini c'est une
question grave sur laquelle je me suis
déjà exprimé hier est effectivement
l'ensemble des témoignages du document
relayé par la presse des documents
fournis par les organisations de défense
des droits de l'homme
l'ensemble de ces témoignages sur la
situation au xinjiang fait état de
pratiques injustifiable qui ne peuvent
être ignorées
elle vend à l'encontre des principes
universels inscrits dans les grandes
conventions internationales des droits
de l'homme
nous parlons d'internement des ouigours
deux camps de détention massive nous
parlons de disparition de travail forcé
de destruction du patrimoine culturel
ouigours en particulier des lieux de
culte de la surveillance de la
population est plus beau plus
globalement de tout un système répressif
mis en place dans cette région nous ne
pouvons accepter cette situation et nous
nous sommes exprimés à de nombreuses
reprises avec nos partenaires européens
nous avons marqué nos grave
préoccupation à l'égard en particulier
de des camps d'internement et dont nous
avons demandé la fermeture et nous
continuerons mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs a condamné fermement ces
pratiques
je constate que les autorités chinoises
ont réagi aujourd'hui à mes propos nous
avons bien pris note de leurs réponses
mais pour autant nos positions restent
maintenues et elles sont bien connues
des autorités chinoises puisque le
présent la république lorsqu'il s'est
rendu en chine en novembre dernier on
avait fait part avec beaucoup de fermeté
nous poursuivrons notre action et il ya
une certaine manière une solution simple
qui serait que la chine permettent
l'accès des observateurs internationaux
du conseil des droits de l'homme de la
haute commissaire aux droits de l'homme
madame bachelet de se rendre sur place
pour faire
toute la lumière sur cette situation ce
serait la bonne réponse pour informer
l'opinion publique mondiale de la
gravité des faits dans cette région jean
jacques monsieur vallini
mais monsieur le ministre nous prenons
acte de vos déclarations nous
désapprouvons bien sûr mais nous pensons
que ça ne suffit pas la france doit agir
de deux façons au niveau européen
en initiant des sanctions économiques
contre la chine avec ses partenaires et
au niveau international en enclenchant
le processus qui pourrait conduire la
chine demain à rendre compte de ses
actes devant une juridiction
internationale
certes nous avons des intérêts
économiques avec la chine
personne ne l'ignorent mais la
concurrence chinoise elle est déjà là l
état pitoyable
elle est sans scrupules et la chine est
une dictature qui ne connaît qu'une
règle comme toutes les dictatures
le rapport de force alors rien ne sert
de redouter la guerre commerciale
parce que nous avons déjà la guerre mais
nous aurons aussi le déshonneur si nous
n'agissons pas monsieur le ministre
depuis longtemps depuis victor hugo ici
même dans cet hémicycle du sénat depuis
le général de gaulle à phnom penh en 66
depuis françois mitterrand en 1982 à
cancun
la france a toujours pris la défense des
peuples opprimés partout sur la terre et
aujourd'hui encore il revient au
gouvernement qu'elles vous appartenez il
revient au président de la république de
se montrer à la hauteur de l'histoire à
la hauteur de notre histoire
merci beaucoup
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
dany wattebled pour le groupe les
indépendants vous avez la parole
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
avant toute chose je tiens à saluer
l'accord européen qui a été trouvé dans
la nuit de lundi à mardi
émanant de position franco-allemande
solide l'europe est rendu son histoire
elle fait preuve de solidarité et nous
en jeu réjouissons mais je le retiens
dans l'accueil européenne que le chiffre
13 13 pour 13 milliard d'euros c'est le
montant de la vente d'apple qui était
année julie dernier par le tribunal de
l'union européenne la commission
réfléchit je cite aux prochaines étapes
possibles pour moi elles sont claires
adopter une fiscalité du numérique
efficace et mordez et moderniser la
politique de concurrence en europe soit
dernier point vous n'avez sans travaux
du sénat contiennent des conventions
pertinentes
nous ne pouvons plus accepter que le
gars femmes payent des impôts dérisoire
au regard de leurs profits et que la
distorsion de concurrence en matière
fiscale soit rennes au sein de l'union
européenne
elle a aussi le sport préféré pratiqués
par les entreprises venant de pays tiers
monsieur le ministre je connais votre
détermination à serait une taxe
numérique au niveau de l' ocde de
l'europe
force est de constater que le dossier
sensible et que l'échelon européen
bien que pertinent reste semé d'embûches
dont la plus importante est certainement
l'unanimité ayons le courage de créer un
noyau dur sur ce sujet qui à terme
entraînera d'autres états en sont à une
coopération renforcée efficace je
mettrai à soulever deux points qui
semblent primordiaux dans le cas de la
relance premièrement quelles sont les
prochaines étapes que la france
entrevoit concernant le dossier de la
taxation numérique et l'actu sion de la
politique de concurrence européenne
l'urgence est là deuxièmement à quand le
début une harmonisation fiscale réaliste
au niveau européen
on vous répondent la parole et à
monsieur olivier du soap ministre
délégué chargé des comptes publics
devaient la parole merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur bat blade
votre question fait écho aux travaux du
sénat vous l'avait dit et tout au long
de ce week-end à l'occasion de l'examen
du projet de loi de finances
rectificative numéro 3 nous avons
échangé sur la pertinence l'utilité
qu'il ya attaque télé gafa à taxer les
activités numériques
vous avez souligné combien sa tante de
propositions est importante
le gouvernement partage beaucoup d
orientation vous avez rappelé la
nécessité d'une harmonisation européenne
la nécessité aussi de mettre fin aux
distorsions de concurrence et nous avons
pu constater partager plutôt un constat
pour dire que ces entreprises sont des
multinationales avec des actifs pour la
plupart incorporels avec la possibilité
aussi de réaliser des profils vraiment
rapidement sur un marché sans présence
physique et les particularités la
particularité aussi d'être
particulièrement délocalisables il faut
apporter une réponse et nous savons que
la les règles de fiscalité
internationale ne sont pas adaptés pour
mettre fin à cette distorsion
vous l'avez dit vous-même la meilleure
réponse et internationales c'est la
position du gouvernement
nous avons pris dans tes déjà une
initiative avec la mise en place en
france d'une taxe gafa qui va en 2020
rapporté plus de 300 millions d'euros à
notre état c'est une initiative et c'est
une forme d'encouragement des autres
pays des partenaires de la france à agir
d'autres pays comme l'italie l'espagne
l'indonésie ou encore la turquie ont
réalisé la même démarche et et nous
accompagnent dans cet effort pas plus
tard que samedi dernier
le cd a à nouveau affirmé la volonté
d'une position commune et a fixé comme
objectif de trouver un accord
international sur la question de la
fiscalité du numérique d'ici la fin de
l'année
mais au delà si le ces deux dates
avancées nous la soutenons au delà de
l'initiative nationale
nous partageons votre propos lorsque
vous dites que le premier échelon le
plus pertinent pour agir et celui de
l'europe
vous avez souligné avec raison caractère
historique de l'accord intervenu ce
week-end lors du sommet européen et à
l'occasion cet accord comme le président
de la république l'a rappelé hier soir
la question du numérique a été posée à
un moment où l'europe doit aussi
s'interroger sur ses propres ressources
l'harmonisation de têtes présentes et
c'est en ce sens que la france travaille
pour partager avec vous ce combat et
faire en sorte que le numérique ce ne
sont plus une activité qui bénéficie
d'une telle distorsion
merci tablette quelques secondes
quelques secondes
merci monsieur le ministre pour ces
éléments il est également urgent
d'adapter une petite panne de la
concurrence pour créer des dg en face
aux autres états mondiaux mais si la
parole est notre collègue françois noël
buffet pour le groupe l'est républicain
le président monsieur président ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le garde
des sceaux mais il l'informé nous
informer qu'il ne pouvait être là depuis
quelques semaines les actes de violences
de nature délictuelle ou criminelle se
multiplient à l'égard de policiers à
l'égard de gendarmes à l'égard de
pompiers ou tout simplement à l'égard de
nos concitoyens nous a indiqué monsieur
le premier ministre que vous souhaitiez
recréer les juges de proximité s'ils ont
tous les cas c'est ce que nous avons
compris le garde des sceaux vient de
dire que ce n'est pas du tout le cas
il voulait plutôt une justice qui soit
plus proche de nos concitoyens
dont acte la crise sanitaire que nous
venons de vivre a démontré une fois de
plus et a re mis en exergue les
difficultés de notre justice tant sur le
plan matériel notamment et de capacité à
pouvoir se mobiliser et à agir que
comptez-vous faire aujourd'hui
d'abord de questions plus d'actes mans
quelle est la politique pénale que vous
ce que le gouvernement souhaite porter à
l'égard de ces deux actes de violence
qui se multiplient parce que lui
finalement les délinquants n'ont plus
peur de rien ou ne craignent plus rien
et 2 surtout quels moyens
allez-vous donner à notre justice pour
pouvoir est à la hauteur de ces enjeux
pour vous répondre la parole pour
secrétaire d'état auprès du premier
ministre porte parole du gouvernement
monsieur attal merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur françois
noël buffet je vous prie d'excuser
l'absence de mon collègue garde des
sceaux eric dupond-moretti qui avait
prévu d'être présent pour vous répondre
et a dû se rendre en urgence à roanne où
vous le savez une prise d'otage a eu
lieu au centre
pénitentiaire et il m'a chargé de vous
répondre
vous avez vous l'avait indiqué il ya eu
des violences qui ont été commises
récemment à lyon et dans sa région et
des réponses pénales qui ont été donnés
depuis la fin des mesures de confinement
liés à l'état d'urgence sanitaire ces
violences ces rodéos sauvages se sont
multipliés ils sont absolument
inacceptables
il appelle une réponse à la fois fermes
immédiate est implacable et je peux à
cet égard répondre à votre première
question qui est celle de la politique
pénale à l'égard de ces faits la
politique pénale arrêté par le procureur
de la république de lyon est celle d'un
déferrement systématique des
participants identifié et interpellé en
vue d'être jugés immédiatement au s'il
s'agit d'un mineur en vue d'être
immédiatement présenté à un juge des
enfants vous avez indiqué aussi qu'il y
avait eu des violences contre les
personnes dépositaires de l'autorité au
cours des représentants de la république
je pense notamment aux pompiers
déploient sapeurs pompiers qui ont été
pris à partie en intervention à la suite
d'un incendie de véhicule le 14 juillet
là aussi la réponse pénale a été tout
aussi clair puisque les auteurs de ces
faits identifiés ont également été
déférées immédiatement et un jeune
majeur a été condamné à un an
d'emprisonnement dont six mois ferme
avec incarcération immédiate pour ces
chefs d'accusation et pour les violences
qui ont été commises plus globalement
vous revenez sur les objectifs de notre
politique pénale qui sont portées par
eric dupond moretti
le garde des sceaux je répondrais
forcément moins bien que lui à cette
question là et je suis sûr qu'il aura
l'occasion de revenir devant vous pour
en parler mais ce qu'a indiqué eric
dupond moretti
c'est notre souhait d'avoir une justice
rétablit dans ses moyens en proximité
pour respecter un principe qui je pense
nous rassemble tous un délit une
sanction est une sanction effectuer une
sanction effective et pour ça oui il
faut des moyens notamment dans les
territoires et je crois qu eric dupond
moretti a été clair sur le fait qu'il
avait des gages sur ce point qu'il
aurait l'occasion de présenter un budget
en hausse pour lui donner les moyens de
cette ambition que nous partageons je
vous remercie
merci monsieur buffet merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre je ne
doute pas de votre volonté
la qualité de vos réponses mais tout de
même compte tenu de ce que nous avons
constaté depuis de nombreuses années sur
les moyens dont dispose notre justice il
y as extrême urgence à mobiliser à la
fois les fonds et à mobiliser les
personnels pour clairement mettre en
place les dispositifs qui permettent de
mener cette politique pénale que vous
revendiquez et que nous pouvons
évidemment largement partagée mais nous
avons souvent entendu à cette tribune
que les moyens allaient donner que l'on
allait agir et nous avons souvent rien
vu venir
donc ce que nous vous demandons monsieur
le monsieur le premier je me permets de
m'adresser à vous c'est véritablement de
faire très très vite
la qualité de notre justice la qualité
de la réponse pénale au sida responsive
il de réponse civile c'est évidemment en
premier la confiance de nos concitoyens
dans notre système judiciaire
à défaut de cette confiance nous nous
aurons des jours mauvais merci aux
autres merci la parole est à notre
collègue michel lui bien pour le groupe
de l'union centriste avait la parole il
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de la santé
elle porte sur les voyageurs qui
arrivent par avion de l'étranger nous
comprenons monsieur le ministre les
contrôles à l'arrivée soit très
difficile à mettre en oeuvre
cependant il existe un moyen de remédier
à cette difficulté exiger la
présentation d'un test négatif au départ
le problème de la déficience des
contrôles sanitaires dans les aéroports
ne date pas d'aujourd'hui
nous avons alerté dès le 1er avril
l'affichage la présence des services
sanitaires ou une attestation sur
l'honneur sont notoirement insuffisants
les études épidémiologiques montrent et
démontrent que c'est de l'étranger que
de nombreux foyers de contamination
réapparaissent sur le territoire
national or rien n'a changé depuis
quatre mois il aura fallu attendre le 17
juillet dernier pour qu'un décret
prévoit la mise en quarantaine
volontaire de personnes venant de
l'étranger
présentant des symptômes ou n'ayant pas
un test négatif à l'agoa 8 19 mais ce
décret n'entrera en vigueur que dans
trois jours bien plus sa portée n'est
pas national puisque ces mesures
devraient être prises par les préfets
dans ce même temps nombre de pays aux
soumis l'autorisation d'accéder à leurs
sols aux seules personnes ayant présenté
dans le pays de départ un test négatif
quel que soit leur nationalité
la chine vient de le faire ce qui évite
la situation ubuesque des contrôles
impossible à l'arrivée des quarantaines
invérifiable mais pourquoi ne le faisons
nous pas également au moins pour les
voyageurs venant de pays à risque ou
deux pays a mis en oeuvre de telles
mesures
je vous remercie pour vous répondre la
parole et au ministre des solidarités de
la santé chez ministre mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice je viens je vous remercie pour
votre question qui permet peut-être de
clarifier un certain nombre de choses
tout d'abord quand vous dites que des
mesures de 14 n s'impose depuis le 17
juillet la sénatrice il ya eu avant
l'état d'urgence sanitaire et après
l'état d'urgence sanitaire et l'état
d'urgence sanitaire prévoyez les mesures
de 14 heures obligatoires même la
sénatrice sans polémiquer en aucune
manière
j'ai de la mémoire vous aussi j'ai passé
dans cet hémicycle un certain nombre
d'heures on peut ressortir si vous
voulez les verbatim de mes différentes
interventions ainsi que les vidéos qui
sont publiés sur le site de public sénat
sur lesquels vous prendrez connaissance
un certain nombre de débats que nous
avons pu avoir sur le texte qui porte
est sorti l'état d'urgence sanitaire et
d'un certain nombre de tentatives pour
lesquelles je n'ai pas rencontré un
franc succès qui visait à ne pas
totalement nous désarmer bien que nous
soyons sortis l'état d'urgence sanitaire
pour peut mettre en place encore un
certain nombre de mesures de protection
des personnes en france
vous vous en souvenez bien parmi ces
mesures qui ne sont plus possibles hors
de l'état d'urgence sanitaire il y en a
une qui consisterait à imposer un
citoyen français en france de faire un
test pcr
on peut le demander c'est ce que nous
faisons madame la sénatrice pour toutes
les personnes qui viennent des pays dans
lesquels le virus circule nous leur
demandons instamment de présenter les
résultats d'un test négatif est réalisé
dans les 72 heures
c'est dans leur départ si les personnes
n'ont pas réalisé ce tête
si les personnes n'ont pas réalisé le
test que nous leur demandons pourtant
bien mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
de réaliser dans les 72 heures avant
qu'il quitte le pays dont ils sont
originaires
et qu'ils arrivent en france nous leur
donnons deux possibilités ou produire
les résultats d'un test négatif réalisés
dans les 48 heures et pour faciliter la
vie des voyageurs nous avons mis en
place nous sommes l'un des seuls pays à
l'avoir fait des plateformes de tests
pcr au sein même des aéroports capable
d'ores et déjà de faire 2000 tests par
jour gratuit pris en charge et remboursé
par la sécurité sociale
sans quoi nous leur demandons de
respecter madame la sénatrice mme une
quatorzaine à domicile et nous les
accompagnons dans la réalisation de
cette 14ème j'entends votre question les
faits sont têtus benhamza messieurs les
sénateurs il ya d'ailleurs des documents
qui en attestent
et qui sont envoyées à tous les
voyageurs en instant arrivée sur notre
territoire national je ne dis pas je ne
dis pas que la solution est parfaite
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs mais
que n'avez vous pas que ne vais vous
pensé à cela au moment où nous avaient
désarmé dans la loi et ce que nous avons
souhaité sortir de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire
voilà médias
je ne doute pas monsieur le ministre
votre volonté mais on ne peut que
constater que ça ne fonctionne pas ça ne
fonctionne pas
la parole est le prix que les grandes
régates cela pour le groupe de la
république en marche
merci monsieur le président mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse
s'il vous plaît à monsieur et madame
frédéric vidal ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche
madame la ministre il ya un an et demi
'l'annonce d'un projet de loi de
programmation pluriannuelle pour la
recherche avec quelque chose d'assez
visionnaire puisque jamais une telle loi
n'avait instauré dans ce domaine d'où
d'ailleurs
non mais vous avez autre chose à dire un
témoin qui préside monsieur gâteau va
continuer à merci monsieur le président
aujourd'hui dans le contexte de crise
économique et sanitaire que nous
traversons est laid mais chaque collecte
ou simplement salutaire est
indispensable cette crise a en effet
souligné combien la recherche est un
élément indissociable à la souveraineté
nationale
combien il est nécessaire de doter la
recherche de moyens budgétaires au long
cours tente elle a besoin de constance
et de visibilité en terme d'engagement
financier en ce sens l'investissement de
25 milliards d'euros sur dix ans que
prévoit la lpr va dans le bon sens tout
comme l'augmentation significative des
dotations de l' agence nationale de la
recherche
permettez-moi néanmoins madame la
ministre d'attirer votre attention sur
les chercheurs eux-mêmes qui sont les
piliers de la recherche dans notre pays
nombre d'entre eux continuent à quitter
la france pour d'autres pays pour ne pas
citer notamment les états unis
il ne la quitte pas par vénalité non ils
la quittent parce qu'ailleurs les
budgets alloués à la recherche
permettent tout simplement de faire et
de bien faire leur métier
aussi madame la ministre ma question est
simple
avec ce texte qu'est ce qui changera
concrètement pour les chercheurs en
termes de conditions de travail et avez
vous des éléments chiffrés et des
engagements précis à nous transmettre à
ce sujet je vous remercie on vous répond
apparu terrabilis de l'enseignement
supérieur de la recherche l'innovation
alain vidal vous avez la parole merci
monsieur le président madame et
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur gâteau là vous
l'avez rappelé est le plus grand
investissement qu'un gouvernement est
fait sur la recherche depuis l'après
guerre
et évidemment ce sera très important
pour moi que nous puissions échanger
dans les prochaines semaines et les
prochains mois
à propos de ce projet de loi qu'est ce
que ce projet de loi prévoit d'abord il
prévoit de reconnaître l'engagement le
travail
l'ensemble des missions assurées par les
chercheurs par les
enseignants-chercheurs au service de la
production de la connaissance et au
service de notre société au sens le plus
large puisque vous le savez ce sont ses
connaissances qui nous celle d'hier qui
nous ont permis d'affronter les crises
d'aujourd'hui et celles qui vont être
produites à partir d'aujourd'hui qui
nous permettra je n'en doute pas
d'affronter les crises de demain alors
vous demander qu'est ce qui va changer
concrètement tout d'abord une
simplification qui vient du terrain
plusieurs mois depuis plusieurs mois
nous travaillons avec l'ensemble des
laboratoires avec l'ensemble des
chercheurs des enseignants chercheurs
pour voir qu'est ce qui très
concrètement les empêche d'exercer leur
métier ils ont besoin de temps et c'est
pourquoi il y aura des créations
d'emploi supplémentaires pour
accompagner les chercheurs et les
enseignants chercheurs dans tous les
métiers de la recherche ils ont besoin
de reconnaissance c'est pourquoi il y
aura une revalorisation sans précédent
pour l'ensemble des métiers de la
recherche
ils ont besoin de moyens c'est pourquoi
nous prévoyons non seulement de porter
le budget de l'agencé nationale de la
recherche un milliard d'euros mais que
s'ajoute aussi 450 millions d'euros qui
viendront alimenter la recherche de base
au travers de l' agence nationale de la
recherche
mais pas pour autant sur des projets
ciblés simplement parce que lorsqu'une
équipe gagne dans un laboratoire c'est
l'ensemble du laboratoire qui gagne
c'est l'ensemble des autres équipes qui
ont aidé le chercheur dans son anr
c'est une grande joie pour la recherche
et je serai très fier de la beauté
devant vous je vous remercie
jusque là oui très rapidement merci
madame la ministre je crois que un point
quand même important dans le monde de la
recherche vers la france ne se classe
pas dans les meilleures positions dans
le domaine des sciences sociales et
humaines et il y aura un effort en
particulier en termes de compétition
internationale à faire puisqu'on le voit
nous échouons malheureusement très
souvent dans les contrats et des appels
d'offres qui sont lancés au niveau
repères je vous remercie
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
catherine procaccia pour le groupe des
républicains
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre ma question
concerne aussi le retard que prend la
france dans le contrôle aux frontières
et dans les aéroports
et si ma question ressemble à celle de
madame vullien c'est parce que c'est une
préoccupation des parlementaires et des
français il n'y a quasiment aucun
contrôle qu'ovide autre que les relevés
de température qui sont mis en place
place par les exploitants et que l'état
n'a pas rendu obligatoire il y a surtout
plusieurs heures d'attentes aux arrivées
dans les aéroports qui mélange les
voyageurs de plusieurs avions sans
respect des gestes-barrières sans
distinction entre français et étrangers
et surtout sans aucun suivi
et quoi que vous nous ayez répondu
monsieur le ministre
aucun certificat médical ni résultats de
tests négligé pour l'instant quelle que
soit la zone d'où arrivent les voyageurs
et même si les autorités locales
décident de mesures de confinement comme
par exemple à barcelone et compte de
l'united inutilité cette attestation sur
l'honneur assurant que l'on n'a pas le
coc vide que personne ne réclame et
alors qu'une grande partie des malades
sont asymptomatiques
ce constat alarmant est dénoncée par
tous et particulièrement par les
médecins hospitaliers qui voit arriver
de plus en plus de binationaux et
d'étrangers contaminée qui n'ont eu
aucun suivi depuis leur atterrissage une
nouvelle fois la france prend du retard
une nouvelle fois elle est incapable de
mettre en place autrement que sur le
papier ce que presque tous nos voisins
font des contrôles aux frontières
systématique pas seulement incitatif et
au bon vouloir du passage
et ne parlons pas des 2000 tests pcr
journalier annoncée alors que ce sont
près de 20 mille voyageurs qui arrivent
chaque jour de ces zones rouges
ma question est simple allez vous mettre
en place des contrôles obligatoires est
réel et éviter que nous aéroports ne
deviennent des passoires aco vide on
nous répond la parole autour des listes
de solidarité et de la santé dix
secondes
la sénatrice pro cassia il me faudrait
plus de deux minutes pour répondre
factuellement à la question que vous
avez posé ne serait ce que pour
présenter les chiffres quand vous dites
la dangerosité vient de l'étranger
j'ai demandé figurez-vous aux hôpitaux
parisiens de m'indiquer combien de
malades ans originaires de l'étranger et
est actuellement hospitalisé dans les
réanimations si on exclut les repeints
les rapatriements sanitaires de français
que nous avons donc rapatrié dans nos
hôpitaux parce qu'ils étaient gravement
malades à l'étranger
nous parlons sur l'ensemble des hôpitaux
parisiens et depuis la date du 15 juin
de cinq malades
je ne dis pas que ça ne compte pas
madame la sénatrice je dis juste que
quand vous dites que le je vous dis que
lorsque vous dites que la dangerosité
bien l'étranger les chiffres encore une
fois sont têtus quand vous dites que
tous nos voisins ont mis en place des
mesures draconiennes drastique
obligatoires madame la sénatrice je vous
demande de venir me voir après la séance
nous appelons nous appellerons ensemble
comme je lé fais l'ensemble des
ministres de la santé des pays du
conseil européen et vous constaterez
avec moi que à part la france il n'y a
pas encore véritablement d'autres pays
européens qui mis en place des contrôles
pcr disponibles jusque dans les
aérogares des aéroports maintenant
madame la sénatrice parlons parlons
sérieusement tous deux secondes pour
tester mille personnes dans un aéroport
il faut une équipe de 40 personnes pour
tester 35000 personnes dans un aéroport
c'est le nombre de passagers qui est
attendu à par exemple à roissy en
période pré estivale vrai le compte et
avec moi il faut 1200 nous pouvons le
faire nous pouvons demander à 1200
personnes d'être en permanence à
l'aéroport de mettre en place un tri est
demandé à tous les passagers de passer
plusieurs heures dans la tente des
aérogares nous pouvons effectivement
envisagée pour sa madame la sénatrice
encore une fois il nous faudrait une
disposition législative que nous n'avons
plus parce qu'elle a été désamorcée dans
le débat parlementaire et notamment je
le redis parce qu'il faut assumer
cette madame g messieurs les sénateurs
dans le cadre du débat sénatorial par la
majorité sénatoriale maintenant madame
la sénatrice pour tous les
ressortissants tous les ressortissants
qui ne sont pas bi nationaux et qui
viennent de pays qui sont classées rouge
c'est-à-dire dans lesquels le virus
circule plus qu'en france ils ne peuvent
pas rentrer et nous nous sommes en train
de parler deux ressortissants
binationaux des français qui sont dans
des pays où le virus circule beaucoup et
qui reviennent en france à qui je le
confirme
nous demandons de réaliser sur place un
test dans les 72 heures et si le test
n'est pas disponible dans les pays parce
que ça peut arriver notamment dans les
pays rouges
nous mettons en place des tests à
l'aéroport et nous les accompagnons dans
une quatorzaine le cas échéant jusqu'à
ce qu'ils puissent bénéficier d'un test
croyez moi nous sommes déterminés sur ce
sujet nous n'avons certainement pas
envie de permettre au virus de circuler
d'où qu'ils viennent
que ce soit de l'international ou de
l'étranger accompagnez nous dans les
dispositifs législatifs accompagnez-nous
et soyez fiers un peu de ce que nous
sommes capables de mettre en oeuvre pour
protéger les français
[Applaudissements]
l'impro cassia vous avez quelques
secondes merci vous dites monsieur le
ministre qu'il ya très peu originaire de
l étranger j'ai bien dit qu'il y avait
des binationaux qui était dans les
hôpitaux je ne vais pas inventer c'est
dans toute la précédente tous les
journaux et puis quand on se détend de
monsieur le premier ministre parle de
fermer la frontière avec l'espagne
est-ce qu'il faut attendre qu'un jour un
décret pour faire en sorte que l'on
contrôle les gens qui arrivent de
barcelone ce n'est pas fait et est ce
qu'on va faire comme la dernière fois
avec l'italie font le lien avait fermé
les frontières et on a continué à les
accueillir sans aucun contrôle
on est inquiets monsieur le ministre
merci la parole et la voilà mme la
présidente hélène commémoré pour le
groupe socialiste et républicain vélo
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre vous connaissez parfaitement
l'enseignement supérieur vous en est
issu vous ne pouvez ignorer ces
problèmes
vous les avez vécu alors il est
difficile de comprendre pourquoi dès
votre arrivée à la tête de ce grand
ministère qui préparent l'avenir de nos
jeunes mais également de notre pays
vous n'avez pas lancer immédiatement un
grand plan de relance global sur le
quinquennat afin de rattraper les sous
investissements structurels dont
souffrent nos universités les
investissements étaient insuffisants
depuis 20 ans c'est un fait mais
aujourd'hui c'est le problème majeur
il faudrait ouvrir une nouvelle faculté
tous les ans pour accueillir les plus de
trente mille étudiants supplémentaires
la dotation par étudiant ne cesse de
baisser pour être aujourd'hui au niveau
de 2008
ce problème financier pèse également sur
l'emploi avec une baisse très nette des
recrutements due à la précarisation de
l'emploi des enseignants chercheurs à
laquelle vous commencez enfin de
répondre par la lpp airs que vous avez
présenté ce matin en conseil des
ministres cependant 99% des 25 milliards
annoncés ne seront disponibles qu'après
de plus ces crédits qui repose sur des
appels à projets ne sont pas garanties
les universités ont besoin de moyens
maintenant et ne peuvent attendre le
prochain quinquennat madame la ministre
nous venons d'examiner trois plfr dans
lesquelles vous aviez l'occasion de
garantir des crédits afin de financer
vos annonces et pourtant vous attendez
deux jours après la fin des débats pour
annoncer l'ouverture de dix mille places
supplémentaires que vous financez commet
aucune aide non plus pour la création
pendant l'été d'un enseignement à
distance qui retient pourtant des
investissements alors que vous avez
refusé ici comme à l'assemblée nationale
tous les amendements qui tendait à
soutenir les doctorants et des boursiers
pour la rentrée prochaine
rassurez-nous madame la ministre en nous
disant que vous avez réservé tous vos
efforts pour le plf à venir l'apparent
les cas graves la milice l'enseignement
supérieur de la recherche et
l'innovation en abidal la parole
merci beaucoup le président mais les
sénatrices monsieur le sénateur madame
la présidence
la présente comme amour et jeu je
comprends le sens de votre question je
pense que nous partageons l'idée
qu'effectivement il est temps de
réinvestir massivement dans la recherche
dans notre pays
mais je voudrais peut-être apporter des
précisions sur ce que vous venez sur ce
que vous venez de dire vous dit rien
n'est prévu pour que l'on prévoit d
enseignement à distance à la rentrée
c'est 30 millions d'euros madame qui
sont à la disposition des établissements
d'enseignement supérieur pour préparer
cette rentrée universitaire avec des
formations à distance vous dites que le
financement des doctorants n'est pas
assurée nous avons prolongé d'une année
la possibilité d'avoir des contrats
doctoraux financer et c'est la même
chose pour les à terre et pour un
certain nombre de post doctorants vous
dites que nous devrions construire une
université par an vous le savez comme
moi la construction d'une université ça
se prévoit c'est dans les années 2000
que l'on savait que la courbe
démographique atteindra son pic en 2018
je suis arrivé ce gouvernement est
arrivé en 2017 ça nous était très
compliqué de construire une université
parents et surtout de rattraper le
retard
alors oui le plan étudiants a permis de
réinjecter un milliard d'euros pour
l'accueil spécifique des étudiants en
premier cycle
oui aujourd'hui ce sont 25 milliards
d'euros qui vont être consacrés et
réinvestit à la rochelle pour la
recherche c'est vous donner un ordre de
grandeur 50 millions d'euros sur le
programme recherche 172 entre 2012 et
ses 201 millions dès l'année prochaine
c'est 559 millions l'année suivante ça
veut dire qu'en deux ans nous aurons
fait seize fois plus qu entre 2012 et
oui on pourrait toujours espérer plus
mais parfois le mieux est l'ennemi du
bien
je préfère que nous commencions à
investir sincèrement est réellement dans
l'enseignement supérieur et la recherche
vous remercie madame que nous avons
madame la présidente c'est vrai que nous
sommes habitués à une communication avec
des superlatifs mais aujourd'hui je
crois que nous avons besoin d'une vision
globale pour pour les universités et
surtout il ya une grande inquiétude pour
la rentrée prochaine peut-être pas de
sens de savoir est ce que nous attendons
et sachez que le sénat sera au
rendez-vous prochain en tout cas pour
voter des crédits si cela était avancée
pour votre ministère nous l'avons été
avec les repas à 1 euro mais nous avons
besoin de soutenir nos universités leur
personnel et les étudiants
la parole est entre collègues christine
bonfanti beau font-ils hausse de ressort
pour le groupe l'est républicain de la
barre haut merci merci monsieur le
président ma question s'adresse
également au garde des sceaux
les récentes propos du garde des sceaux
lors de sa nomination annoncée des
mesures ambitieuses
s'agissant du budget de la justice qui
serait et je le cite un budget que la
justice n'a pas connu depuis longtemps
il affiche est ainsi sa volonté de
réforme mais c'est à la faveur d'une
interview donnée au jdd qui l'a amoindri
les espoirs nourris par ses premières
déclarations
l'optimisme est alors retombée et les
fed annonce auquel ce quinquennat nous a
habitués n'aura pas survécu bien
longtemps alors j'aurai trois questions
depuis plusieurs années on annonce un
plan de rénovation pour les petites
structures pénitentiaires
ce plan va t'il être entérinée va-t-on
pouvoir enfin commencer les travaux
s'agissant des aménagements de peine
avez vous décidé d'étendre le nombre des
centres de semi-liberté dans les
territoires dont les besoins se font le
plus sentir
l'exemple d'agen dix places seulement
pour le ressort de la cour d'appel du
lot-et-garonne et du gers
allez-vous faire ruisseler ce budget
historique à venir pour les territoires
ruraux les plus fragiles et puis pour
finir
avez vous l'intention de créer ses 15000
e places de prison comme s'y était
engagé le président de la république
même
si le nombre a baissé depuis où avez
vous l'intention de désemplir les
prisons puisque le garde des sceaux a
annoncé lors de sa visite à la prison de
fresnes devant son taux d'occupation
historiquement bas que c'est le chemin
qu'il fallait poursuivre désormais pour
vous répondre
la parole au secrétaire d'état auprès du
premier ministre porte parole du
gouvernement
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice bonfanti dossat jouit à
nouveau d'excuser l'absence de mon
collègue garde des sceaux eric dupond
moretti qui a dû se rendre à roanne où
une prise d'otage a eu lieu au centre de
rétention de la ville
vous m'interrogez vous nous interroger
sur la politique que le gouvernement
entend mener s'agissant notamment des
questions pénitentiaires et je vous
remercie car il s'agit effectivement
d'une priorité
et vous l'avez rappelé dans son discours
de la passation eric dupond moretti est
intervenu très fortement sur ce sujet là
il a effectué son premier déplacement en
tant que garde des sceaux dans un
établissement pénitentiaire et il a eu
l'occasion dans une audition à
l'assemblée nationale
il ya je crois deux jours de revenir sur
ces questions là et d'afficher la même
ambition que celle qu'il a affirmé quand
il a été nommé je suis sûr que dans une
audition où des rencontres au sénat y
pourra revenir sur ce sujet là mais au
fond ce qu'il a indiqué ces trois
objectifs
il ya la question des moyens et de
l'immobilier et sur ce point il ya un
plan qui a été engagée de création de
15000 places de prison avec une première
tranche de 7000 places déjà bien engagé
et des plusieurs milliers de places qui
sont déjà sortis il ya la question des
postes et sur ce point 6500 recrutement
qui ont été effectués depuis le début de
ce quinquennat avec une hausse d'un
quart du budget de la justice
et puis ensuite il ya la question des
conditions de détention et eric dupond
moretti l'a dit nous ne pouvons pas nous
résoudre à ce que la france pays des
droits de l'homme sont régulièrement
condamnée par la cour européenne des
droits de l'homme pour les conditions de
détention de ces détenus et un plan
spécifique sera présenté avant la fin de
l'année sur ce sujet là et puis il ya la
question des peines
et oui il ya une politique pénale qui
vise à renforcer les peines alternatives
à l'incarcération recours au bracelet
électronique tronic le travail d'intérêt
général comme sanction pénale ont
augmenté de 20% depuis trois ans nous
allons poursuivre dans cette voie et
pour revenir sur la question locale que
vous
évoquée oui aucun territoire ne doit
être oublié dans le lot et garonne le
quartier de semi-liberté d'agen que vous
évoquez dispose de dix places
la priorité c'est déjà de faire en sorte
que ces dix places soit occupé puisque à
ce jour selon mes informations seulement
deux détenus
ils sont affectés il faut donc
promouvoir davantage je le disais les
alternatives à l'incarcération
et c'est ce que nous allons poursuivre
avec eric dupond-moretti il faut
remercier madame brooks et de ça oui
monsieur le ministre au fond ce que nous
attendons de nos territoires
c'est la proximité de la justice et pas
la justice de proximité et c'est la
raison pour laquelle je voulais dire au
garde des sceaux que j'espérais qu'ils
gardent à l'esprit cette doctrine
redoutable du général de gaulle entre
possibles et impossibles il n'y a que
deux lettres mais un état de d merci la
parole est à notre collègue alain
cazabonne pour le groupe de l'union
centriste de la parole le président
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues ma question s'adresse au
ministre l'économie
si rien n'est fait avant le 31 juillet
une pépite technologique française
passera ce pavillon américain
cette pépite une entreprise de gironde
ces photos nice leader français de la
vision nordine sur laquelle notre
collègue olivier cadic a déjà attiré
l'attention de gréement à plusieurs
reprises teledyne une entreprise
américaine est prêt à surpayer l'achat
de photos nice pour acquérir cette
technologie la transaction sera possible
à partir du 31 juillet si vous ne vous y
opposez pas formellement
en effet après vérification l'absence de
décision au 31 juillet votre acceptation
et non par j comme il avait été dit au
sénat le gouvernement s'apprête il a
autorisé cette session avec les
précautions d'usagé dont on connaît
parfois la fragilité
l'objectif ne veux pas être dans le
cadre et cette vente car cela
renforcerait un mouvement de fond qui
fragilise la base industrielle et
technologique de la défense
en laissant partir progressivement les
pme qui la constituent le président m'a
kron a déclaré vouloir ramener en france
et d industrie nécessaire à notre
indépendance c'est très bien mais c'est
tout aussi nécessaire de conserver
celles qui sont déjà
alors ma question oui allez vous opposez
votre veto à la disparition d'une
société emblématique du savoir faire
technologique français et affirmer votre
volonté de sauver cette branche
industrielle de la défense en créant
peut-être avec pvi france un tour de
blanc un tour de parole un tour de table
français ou au moins européen pour vous
répondre la parole et communistes
délégué auprès du ministre de l'économie
des finances de la relance
monsieur du soap merci monsieur le
président monsieur le sénateur casabonne
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs vous
interroger le gouvernement sur la
situation de l'entreprise photonis qui
est un groupe international vous l'avez
rappelé implanté aux usa en france aux
pays bas et qui intervient dans un
secteur stratégique qui concerne les
intérêts de la défense nationale
vous comprendrez que cette opération que
vous décrivez impliquant des sociétés
cotées il y a un devoir de
confidentialité sur un certain nombre
d'aspects du dossier qui m'empêcheront
certainement d'être aussi précis que ce
que vous attendez je vais simplement
vous indiquer que depuis l annonce par
le groupe indien de son projet de
cession à l'automne 2010 9 ce dossier
suivi avec la plus grande attention par
le mystère d'économie des finances mais
aussi par le ministère des armées avec
madame florence parly nous avons un
objectif qui est de défendre les
intérêts de la france des intérêts de la
défense nationale en donnant à photo
miss un actionnariat qui soit stable qui
soit serein si vous permettez cette
expression et qui lui permettent de
développer ses investissements de
développer son activité
en réalité il y a de risques et que nous
devons absolument éviter
le premier risque serait la cession un
investisseur étranger capable d'un
transfert technologique rapide ou de
transfert d'informations à des
informations suffisamment sensible pour
qu'elle ne puisse pas être porté à
connaissance d'autre que de nationaux le
deuxième risque serait de faire le choix
ou d'entériner une acquisition par un
actionnaire qui ne serait pas assez
solide
pour permettre à photonis de rester à la
frontière technologique de garder sa
compétitivité
nous avons une décision à prendre vous
l'avez rappelé est en cours
d'instruction de manière extrêmement
méticuleuse et je veux vous indiquer que
si nous devions autorisé l'opération que
vous avez décrite nous le ferions en
faisant jouer toutes les prérogatives
qui sont celles de l'état à la fois des
prérogatives de droit qui peuvent
imposer au repreneur le maintien
d'activités sensibles sur le territoire
national mais aussi des prérogatives qui
peuvent nous amener à imposer des
repreneurs des modifications
substantielles dans la gouvernance qu'il
entre vous qui lente qu'il entrevoit
notamment en matière d'accès à
l'information d'éventuels actionnaires
étrangers ou encore de maintien sur le
territoire d'activités sensibles savait
que ses deux priorités que nous
travaillons que nous examinons le
dossier que très vite nous rendront chez
nos jeunes
merci monsieur mini-sommet de remarques
c'est vrai qu'avec l'expérience de ford
en gironde j'ai vu la limite des
engagements des entreprises et la façon
dont l'état pouvait les obliger à tenir
ses engagements
deuxièmement une suggestion si vous
voulez vous pouvez recevoir notre
collègue centriste olivier cadic kiala
des contacts extrêmement intéressant
pour des fonds pas apparemment intéressé
par la reprise de cette société où le
renforcement de société voilà monsieur
ministre merci la parole est maintenant
notre collègue françois calvet pour le
groupe l'est républicain
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre délégué aux
transports monsieur le ministre le 14
juillet dernier le président de la
république a confirmé sa volonté de
limiter le transport aérien intérieur
sans définir avec précision les contours
de cette limitation
certains territoires de la république
n'ont d'autre alternative que le
transport aérien pour se connecter au
reste du pays
c'est le cas de mon département des
pyrénées orientales
au-delà de la question pure et simple de
la suppression des lignes aériennes se
pose la question de la fréquence des
rotations et de la substitution de
roissy à orly comme aéroport d'arrivée
il est comme vous le savez beaucoup plus
facile de rejoindre paris en venant
d'orly que de roissy enfin il semble que
la compagnie hop s'apprêterait à
modifier sa politique commerciale par
exemple la liaison paris perpignan
serait supprimé je comprends fort bien
les impératifs écologiques qui s'impose
à nous tous mais je souhaiterais que
vous puissiez m'indiquer les conditions
dans lesquelles à l'absence de
transports aériens réguliers le
désenclavement des territoires les plus
éloignées et les plus mal desservies
notamment en matière de transport
ferroviaire pour être assuré le premier
ministre a indiqué qu'il mettrait toute
son énergie pour faire avancer le projet
de la lgv montpellier perpignan
c'est une excellente nouvelle pouvez
vous monsieur le ministre nous donner le
financement et le calendrier de cette
énergie
merci
pour vous répondre la parole et
touristes délégué chargé des transports
au sud d'aoubari et de ghat parole merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur calvet merci pour cette
question qui me permet de revenir sur
quelques uns des des grands axes de
notre politique des transports
depuis le début du quinquennat vous
savez ce gouvernement à oeuvrer à la
fois pour désenclaver les territoires
assurer leur attractivité et bien sûr
verdir l'ensemble des modes de transport
avec le souci la philosophie constante
de bien coordonner les modes de
transport entre eux et de servir les
besoins spécifiques des territoires de
leurs habitants de leur entreprise tous
ces projets tous les projets en tout cas
on était passé à travers cette maille et
le plan de relance que nous préparons
actuellement évidemment revêt de la même
philosophie s'agissant de la desserte
aérienne peut-être préciser que nous
travaillons actuellement en lien avec
les opérateurs
l'opérateur en l'occurrence les
collectivités locales à la reprise à
remonter en charge de la desserte et
c'est aujourd'hui 18 rotations
hebdomadaires qui sont prévues programmé
opérés au départ de perpignan vers paris
roissy actuellement jusqu'à la fin de
l'été et ensuite orly avec la reprise
d'un trafic plus normal
s'agissant de la ligne perpignan paris
vous savez que le groupe air france est
en cours de restructuration sur secteur
domestique mais le projet de
restructuration en lui-même prévoit la
reprise de la ligne par transavia la
filiale à 100 % d'air france s'agissant
enfin de la politique d'investissement
pour le ferroviaire
vous savez je partage avec vous le fait
que la ligne ferroviaire montpellier
perpignan est un axe structurant
seulement au niveau local et régional
mais aussi au niveau national une
concertation a été menée et nous serons
en mesure de faire des annonces
prochainement sur les modalités et le
calendrier et au delà vous savez que
nous travaillons un plan et nous mettons
en oeuvre un plan de régénération très
massif plus de 3 milliards d'euros par
an pour assurer la régularité de l'offre
ferroviaire et la robustesse partout
dans notre territoire je crois monsieur
sénateurs que ces efforts conjugués
signe l'engagement de l'état pour
promouvoir une offre de transport
complète et garantit ainsi
l'attractivité des territoires et
singulièrement du vôtre
monsieur calvet prenons garde monsieur
le ministre à ce que l'aménagement des
territoires ne soit pas une nouvelle
fois la victime des décisions prises
dans la capitale
et pour cela vous le comprendrez je fais
confiance à notre premier ministre
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
yvon collin pour le groupe du
rassemblement démocratique et social
européen
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues
on le sait dans notre pays le tourisme
est particulièrement impacté par la
crise sanitaire aussi les mesures
annoncées par le dernier comité
interministériel du tourisme en faveur
des entreprises de restauration les
cafés l'hôtellerie l'événementiel le
sport la culture sont tout à fait vitale
j'ai cependant deux inquiétudes tout
d'abord je m'interroge sur l'avenir des
petites agences de voyages dont l'
ordonnance du 25 mars dernier sur les
remboursements des prestations
touristiques n'a apporté qu'une réponse
partielle à leurs difficultés
aujourd'hui elle se retrouve dans
l'incertitude financière car prise en
étau entre les demandes des clients et
l'attitude des grands opérateurs
d'hébergement ou de transport qui ne
leur verse pas les acomptes
par ailleurs je m'inquiète aussi sur le
sort des centaines de tpe et de pme des
secteurs connexes du tourisme qui sont
menacés de faillite faute d'un soutien
plus pointus en effet le tourisme c'est
aussi un ensemble de commerces dire des
petites entreprises dans la production a
parfois été arrêté 100% faute de
débouchés
c'est en particulier le cas de la
confiserie française dont l'activité
dépend fortement de celle de
l'événementiel ou décident de loisirs
l'arrêt puis leur démarrage très lent
départ de loisirs des fêtes foraines des
manques de tourisme dans les magasins de
souvenirs ou encore la faible
fréquentation des aéroports
tous ces facteurs risquent de conduire à
la fermeture d'entre eux d'entreprise de
confiserie emblématique de nos savoir
faire régionaux et bien souvent la
fierté de mon patrimoine national je
pense par exemple à la maison pécout en
tarn et garonne
fondée en 1881
que connaît aussi très bien notre
collègue françois bonhomme ici présent
que j'associe d'ailleurs à cette
question cette entreprise exportatrice
de dragées dans le monde entier et
menacé également en raison de l'arrêt de
cérémonie religieuse dans ces conditions
pensez vous monsieur le ministre que le
recours à l'activité partielle
l'accès au fonds de solidarité ou encore
l'exonération de charges sont
suffisantes pour sauver ces entreprises
le gouvernement ne doit-il pas envisager
des aides plus spécifiques pour sauver
la confiserie française et toutes les
petites pme pme connexes au tourisme je
vous remercie
merci pour vos réponses la parole et au
belize délégué chargé des petites et
moyennes entreprises
je suis à la crise et de la parole mais
à monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur yvon collin dès le
début de la crise le gouvernement a mis
en place une très large palette de
mesures pour accompagner l'ensemble des
tpe pme
le fonds de solidarité le prêt garanti
par l'état les exonérations ou l'europe
ans de cotisations sociales et
l'activité partielle de plus le
gouvernement a accordé la possibilité de
reporter les échéances fiscales
le projet de loi rectificative numéro 3
qui a fait l'objet hier d'une commission
mixte paritaire conclusive permettra un
soutien renfoncer de l'état aux
entreprises du secteur du tourisme
incluant les activités opéra en amont et
en aval de ce secteur pour atteindre 31
milliards d'euros pour l'activité
partielle et 9 milliards pour le fonds
de solidarité dont je rappelle que 500
millions sont issus des régions et 400
mio par les assureurs ils sont complétés
par des plans de soutien d'urgence aux
secteurs les plus touchés par la crise
les entreprises des secteurs de
l'hôtellerie restauration café tourisme
événementiel support culture bénéficiant
par ailleurs de mesures renforcées
prises en charge à 100 % de l'indemnité
d'activité partielle jusqu'en septembre
accès au fonds de solidarité jusqu'en
fin 2020 avec un accès élargi aux
entreprises de ces secteurs ayant
jusqu'à 20 salariés et réalisant un
chiffre d'affaires allant jusqu'à 2
millions d'euros et génération de
cotisations patronales à quitter leur
portée
durant les mois de mars à juin pour les
tpe et pme de ces secteurs représentent
une mobilisation de ressources de 43
milliards et demi d'euros au total pour
18 milliards d'euros au profit du
secteur du tourisme
ce projet de loi de finances
rectificative comprend également une
mesure inédite d'exonération de côté
cotisations et contributions sociales
patronales associer un crédit de
cotisation pour près de 3 milliards
d'euros
cette mesure permettra notamment aux tpe
pme des secteurs de l'hôtellerie de la
restauration des cultures de
l'événementiel et du sport et aux tpe
étant frappée d'une interdiction
d'accueil penser à conclure des remises
de cotisations patronales sur demande
le gouvernement restera attentif à
l'écouté des entreprises dans les
prochaines semaines si peu les
nécessaires mesures nouvelles en
fonction du dispositif et en fonction
des conditions de la reprise
merci la parole est à notre collègue
angèle préville pour le groupe
socialiste et républicain
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues le dernier
rapport du haut conseil pour le climat
est accablant les actions climatiques de
la france ne sont pas à la hauteur des
enjeux et les objectifs qu'elle s'est
donnée sous couvert d'affichage
environnemental le gouvernement va droit
dans le mur
et ce n'est pourtant pas faute
d'initiatives parlementaires notre
planète se meurt de notre inaction il ne
s'agit plus d'une opinion mais d'un fait
la région arctique est tous sous la
hausse des températures en sibérie c'est
déjà la question du coût économique qui
se posent
roux détériorer bâtiments fissurés
infrastructures liées à l'exploitation
du gaz menacé et menaçante
nous ne voulons pas être les spectateurs
résigné du dérèglement climatique
lancé en grande pompe la convention
citoyenne pour le climat était
l'occasion de faire participer les
français à la préparation de la loi est
aussi celle de saisir au vol la prise de
conscience environnementale qui grandit
depuis l'accord de paris le troisième
plfr dans un contexte de poussée de la
social écologie au municipal était le
premier test pour concrétiser les
velléités écologique du gouvernement
l'effet d'annoncé a une fois de plus eu
raison des actes et le virage écologique
est repoussée à plus tard
nous n'aurons ni changement de cap ni
relance verte tous nos amendements ici
des propres tissus des propositions de
la convention ont été rejetées la baisse
de la tva sur les billets de train la
prime climat pour éliminer les passoires
thermiques le malice le malus pardon sur
les véhicules polluants l'augmentation
du taux de taxe des dividendes
rien n'y fait ni les alertes de la
communauté scientifique ni la voie des
urnes ni le travail des parlementaires
ni même les propositions d'un groupe de
travail citoyen que vous avez vous même
constitué sur la social-écologie notre
gouvernement reste sourd il est aussi
malade de son manque d'ambition que de
sa doxa libérale peu soucieuse des
conséquences environnementales
quand et comment la loi va-t-elle entrer
en résonance avec l'urgence climatique
pour vous répondre la parole et à
ministre en charge du logement de
l'embargo merci monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs et
sénatrices madame la sénatrice préville
nous allons parler des actes nous avons
aujourd'hui un accord européen inédit
avec un plan de relance que la france
apporte et 750 millions d'euros
d'investissements milliards d'euros par
an dont 750 milliards d'euros
d'investissement 30% de relance verte
c'est totalement inédit 40 milliards
pour la france ça ce sont des actes ça
ce sont des résultats ça ce sont des
choses sonnantes et trébuchantes qui
vont nous permettre d'amorcer
d'accélérer la transition écologique en
france
parlons des actes un plan de relance
français 100 milliards d'euros
d'investissements 30 milliards consacrés
à la transition écologique
parlons des actes une convention
citoyenne par le climat qui a été
installé il y a un an qui a rendu ses
conclusions qui a été reçu par le
président de la république
146 mesures seront reprises sur 149 ça
va toucher la vie quotidienne des
français comment se loger mieux et
rénover nos logements
comment manger mieux avec une transition
agricole qui sera soutenu là encore par
la politique agricole commune
comment se déplacer mieux et les plans
de relance que nous avons déjà annoncé
sur la filière aéronautique sur la
filière automobile nous permettent
d'accélérer cette transition écologique
alors arrêtez les imprécations tous les
états du de l'europe ont salué ce pacte
européen les socialistes espagnols eux
mêmes ont dit que c'était la fin de
l'europe de l'austérité nous sommes au
rendez vous des actes nous sommes au
rendez vous de cette transition
écologique
nous fermons les centrales à charbon
nous avons arrêté europa city
nous avons arrêté notre dame des landes
nous avons arrêté la montagne d'or
regardez les actes ce gouvernement sera
au rendez-vous de la transition
écologique
pas d'après ville merci monsieur le
président donc les actes nous les
attendons encore nous sommes en train de
faire l'expérience douloureuse de nos
limites
il est grand temps de nous réinterroger
sur notre rôle de prédation sur la
nature on dit la disparition annoncée de
l'ours polaire
vous ne pourrez pas dire que vous ne
saviez pas de la beauté du monde
nous ne pouvons faire le deuil face au
désastre à venir simplement parce que
nous sommes ici nous faisons de la
politique avec sincérité et conviction
la parole est à notre collègue
jean-pierre ans pour le groupe l'est
républicain vous avez la parole merci
monsieur le président se prémunissent
mais évidemment le chez les miss mes
chers collègues
quelle mère telle membres des forces de
l'ordre quel enseignant n'a pas entendu
parler des cartouches dit de gaz
hilarant et constater les innombrables
cartouches usagées qui jonchent le sol
de l'espace public
l' usage de cartouches de protoxyde
d'azoté aux effets euphorisants nouvelle
mode pour de trop nombreux jeunes et pas
seulement constitué un danger pour la
santé publique
comme l'ont récemment souligné les
experts de l'agent nationale sanitaire
l'ansès ma question sur ministre
d'autant plus d'actualité que dans mon
département de l'hérault et pas
seulement le gard et j'associe
d'ailleurs à cette question notre
collègue yvette lopez et est également
ce sont des parents conservent très
concernés nous observons que les
communes littorales les communes
littorales connaissent avec la reprise
la saison touristique une vague de
violence grave in aux importantes des
incivilités pour utiliser ce mot pudique
trop souvent causés par l'usagé de ce
gaz
euphorisant le sénat a adopté à
l'unanimité le seul premier ministre à
l'unanimité le 11 décembre dernier une
proposition de loi tendant à protéger
les mineurs des usages dangereux du
protoxyde d'azoté
nous avions adopté des amendements
visant à interdire la vente de
cartouches protoxyde d'azoté par les
sites de commerce en ligne et demandé
qu'une information sur les risques
avérés graves pour la santé sur la santé
parle usage détourné de ce gaz soient
dispensés dans les établissements
scolaires
certains maires et nous ici nous
représentons les maires moi je
représente ceux de l'hérault certains
maires ont pris des arrêtés
d'interdiction d'utilisation de gaz dans
l'espace public c'est le cas de ma
commune mais c'est insuffisant et
juridiquement fragile face à ce double
problème de santé publique et d'ordre
public
je souhaite monsieur le ministre que
l'action du sénat est un prolongement à
l'assemblée nationale et mieux encore
parce que nous aimerions qu'ils décision
soit prise avant le mois avant le mois
d'août
un prolongement à l'assemblée mais
surtout par moyens règlement de faire et
ça vous le pouvez afin de mettre en
oeuvre les mesures votées dans cet
hémicycle contre l'usagé tournée des
cartouches de protoxyde d'azoté avant je
vous en remercie pour vous répondre
la parole est au ministre des
solidarités de la santé monsieur le
ministre
monsieur le sénateur cher jean pierre
grand votre question est importante eu
l'occasion de répondre
il y a quelques semaines à l'assemblée
nationale à une question similaire et je
sais le travail qui a été fourni par les
sénateurs qui est important et notamment
je crois par votre collègue valérie
létard qui était qui a écrit et défendu
une proposition parlementaire de loi qui
a été adoptée ici même à l'unanimité je
crois qu'elles aient perdu la navette
parlementaire qu'elle doit en ressortir
prochainement pour arriver à l'assemblée
nationale où je vous le dis sans ambages
j'aurai à coeur d'accompagner ce texte
voire de le renforcer et d'améliorer
partout où ce sera nécessaire parce que
votre question soulève un vrai problème
de santé publique
et vous le savez toutes et tous ici
puisque vous êtes un certain nombre à
être interpellé par les maires qui font
face au dépôt sauvage de cartouches de
ce gaz qui n'a d'hilarants que le nom et
beaucoup de gens se posent la question
de savoir comment faire comme pour toute
addiction
il ya d'abord les campagnes qui sont
menées par la mission de lutte contre
les addictions d'amyle des cas il ya
également des accompagnements qui
peuvent être faits en addictologie les
k2 de suivi par addictologie ces
quelques dizaines en revanche ce gaz qui
il est vrai à une consommation
extrêmement brève procure une faurie
parfois des hallucinations et régresse
sans laisser de séquelles présente une
dangerosité en réalité qui est ignorée
par les jeunes qui sont trop nombreux à
le consommer notamment la première des
dangerosité je crois que si on arrive
déjà expliqué ce risque aux jeunes ils
seront moins nombreux à considérer que
c'est pas grave de le consommer c'est un
gaz qui est stocké dans des capsules
extrêmement réfrigérée et les cas
d'accidents les plus graves sont des cas
de brûlures mortels l'ensemble des voies
respiratoires et des branches et quand
je dis mortels c'est parce que ça
provoque la mort parce que la
consommation de ces capsules lorsqu'elle
n'est pas maîtrisé et on ne peut pas le
prédire au moment de sortir une capsule
par exemple de deux machines
distributrices de chantilly peut
provoquer le décès et c'est de ce sont
des drames terribles on parle de jeunes
de 18 19 20 ans et qui se retrouve alors
qu'ils ne s'y attendaient pas les
proches ne s'y attendait évidemment
parce qu'ils ignorent la dangerosité et
puis il ya des séquelles neurologiques
qui peuvent apparaître et là c'est le
neurologue qui vous le dit avec des
séquelles qui peuvent être irréversibles
donc sous couvert d'une consommation
d'un produit qu'on peut acheter par
paquets de 100 sur internet qui coûte
pas bien cher et qui fait marrer les
copains en réalité aux mecs gravement sa
vie
en jeu l'action des maires peut être
déterminante via des interdictions
localiser de consommation notamment sur
la voie publique
également dans le repérage des capsules
qui doit donner lieu à un renforcement
des campagnes de prévention en lien avec
la rs en attendant donc cette belle doit
que vous avez commencé
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs à
travailler et que j'espère qui j'espère
verra sa concrétisation d'ici la fin du
mandat
merci chers collègues je vais suspendre
la séance merci monsieur le premier
ministre une âme des messieurs les
ministres de votre présence vous savez
monsieur le produit combien nous sommes
attachés à ces questions au gouvernement
et à votre présence
quand elles reprendront à la rentrée
parlementaire
notre science sera reprise à 16h30 pour
l'examen de trois conventions
internationales dont deux seront
examinés selon la procédure simplifiée
séance est suspendue
voilà pour cette dernière séance de
questions d'actualité de la saison une
séance de questions d'actualité qui a
notamment vu plusieurs questions
adressées au ministre des solidarités de
la santé olivier véran autour bien sûr
de l'épidémie de lakovic 19 plusieurs
questions adressées à olivier véran
notamment sur la gratuité des masques
gratuité qui est réclamée par notamment
et bien les sénateurs communistes depuis
le début de la crise est encore plus
demandés alors que les masques sont
désormais obligatoires dans les lieux
publics clos
le gouvernement prévoit des
distributions pour les plus précaires a
rappelé le ministre et les plus fragiles
mais ils refusent en revanche la
gratuité
notez aussi et bien des échanges tendus
autour de la sécurité sanitaire dans les
aéroports puisqu'il ya eu pas moins de
deux questions sur ce sujet adressé à
olivier véran le ministre estime
d'ailleurs que c'est le sénat qui a
désarmé et la france sont ses mots sur
ce sujet en refusant un certain nombre
de mesures de contrôle pendant la
période de la sortie de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire en a senti que cela faisait
réagir dans l'hémicycle on va bien sûr
revenir sur tout cela jusqu'à 17 heures
avec des invités sur ce plateau mais on
va d'abord commencer par
intéressée à l'état de la justice
puisque eric dupond-moretti nouveau
garde des sceaux a été auditionné en
début d'après midi au sénat
vous avez pu le suivre d'ailleurs en
direct sur notre chaîne il a dû partir
en raison et bien d'une crise une prise
d'otages à un juan qui est une prise
d'otage qui est désormais terminé mais
c'est donc gabriel attal le porte parole
du gouvernement qui a répondu aux
questions sur la justice tout à l'heure
dans l'hémicycle on l'écouté il ya la
question des moyens et de l'immobilier
et sur ce point il ya un plan qui a été
engagée de création de 15000 places de
prison avec une première tranche de 7000
places déjà bien engagé et des plusieurs
milliers de places qui sont déjà sortis
il ya la question des postes et sur ce
point 6500 recrutement qui ont été
effectués depuis le début de ce
quinquennat avec une hausse d'un quart
du budget de la justice
et puis ensuite il ya la question des
conditions de détention et eric dupond
moretti l'a dit nous ne pouvons pas nous
résoudre à ce que la france pays des
droits de l'homme sont régulièrement
condamnée par la cour européenne des
droits de l'homme pour les conditions de
détention de ces détenus et un plan
spécifique sera présenté avant la fin de
l'année sur ce sujet là et pour revenir
sur la question de l'état de la justice
et puis sur cette audition dont je vous
parlais tout à l'heure d'eric
dupond-moretti
philippe bas le président de la
commission des lois est à votre micro
alexandre salle des conférences
effectivement tam philippe bas est ce
que le nouveau ministre de la jutice vue
de la justice pardon vous a convaincu
dans sa mission de redresser le service
public de la justice
monsieur dupont moretti porte sur la
justice le regard du justiciable
il fait des diagnostics que nous pouvons
partager sur la situation de pénurie des
moyens des tribunaux de l'immobilier de
la justice de l'informatique de la
justice sur le manque de greffiers sur
la complexité qui exige de la
simplification l'éloignement qui exige
plus de proximité
nous attendons maintenant de lui plus
que ces diagnostics
nous attendons des réponses et c'est sa
responsabilité de ministre dont il est
en train de prendre toute la mesure
c'est un homme sincère et je crois que
conscients de l'importance de ses
responsabilités il a rappelé qu'il avait
600 jours pour agir
nous attendons lui maintenant que ils
obtiennent l'accroissement des moyens du
service public de la justice
il n'a pas été en mesure d'annoncer
d'arbitrage à ce jour eh bien nous
attendons avec impatience ses arbitrages
nous pensions qu'il avait déjà obtenu
des garanties du premier ministre et du
président de la république nous a
simplement dit qu'il allait reprendre la
trajectoire entre guillemets interrompu
de la loi de programmation pour la
justice car non seulement la loi de
programmation des moyens pour la justice
n'est pas à la hauteur mais en plus elle
n'est pas appliquée nous voulons non
seulement qu'elle soit impliquée mais
aussi que les moyens des tribunaux
soient augmentés et en contrepartie que
les méthodes de la justice soit
modernisée notamment sur le plan
informatique et sur le plan de la
simplification des procédures et de
rapprochement des justiciables et
surtout ses chapitres des pistes sont
ouvertes mais les réponses se font
encore attendre
ça n'est pas pour l'instant un motif de
préoccupation il faut laisser au
ministre le temps de prendre en main ces
dossiers mais il est évident que dans
les prochaines semaines les réponses
devront être apportées
est ce que vous pensez qu'il va mener à
terme cette réforme pour plus
d'indépendance du parquet il al'air
volontariste sur cette question mais la
question est aujourd'hui entièrement du
côté du président de la république
puisque l'assemblée nationale et le
sénat ont voté il ya plusieurs années
déjà une révision de la constitution sur
la nomination des procureurs
cette révision n'est pas l'urgence de la
justice l'urgence de la justice c'est le
service public qu'il fonctionne bien à
la satisfaction des français mais il y à
une réforme qui est en cours et la
procédure constitutionnelle
c'est soit le référendum soit la réunion
du congrès le ministre a paru annoncé
tout à l'heure qui est le président
allait réunir le congrès et puis à la
fin de l'audition il s'est ravisé et
bien attendons la décision du président
de la république
attendons de voir la décision d'
emmanuel macron alors autre question qui
concerne l'état d'urgence sanitaire le
ministre de la santé olivier ferrand
durant cette séance de questions
d'actualité a été beaucoup critiquée par
les sénateurs sur le manque de contrôle
virologique dans les aéroports et le
ministre de la santé a répété à
plusieurs reprises que c'était le sénat
qui l'avait désarmé au niveau législatif
pour contraindre les ressortir les
ressortissants de l'étranger et des pays
à risque à faire ces contrôles qu'est ce
que vous lui répondez
j'ai envie de vous dire que de mon point
de vue le rôle d'un ministre est d'être
impartial et pas de lancer des
polémiques la loi sortie de l'état
d'urgence sanitaire a été votée par les
deux chambres en accord avec le
gouvernement et si elle n'est pas bonne
monsieur verrons peut d'abord s'en
prendre à lui même mais je considère que
cette loi offre tous les moyens
nécessaires
elle prévoit le test de dépistage avant
l'embarquement pour la france la
vérification que ce texte est négatif et
dans l'hypothèse où il y aurait des
personnes contaminées
la mise en quarantaine enfin une
quarantaine qui dure en réalité sept
jours et les la loi donne au
gouvernement évidemment tous les moyens
d'agir
il serait vain de se défausser sur le
parlement des responsabilités qui
incombent à l'exécutif
je crois que il ya eu sans doute un
excès d'emportement de la part d'un
ministre qui a pris ses fonctions il ya
quelques mois et qui doit raison garder
et garder son objectivité aussi merci
beaucoup au chili bat pour votre
réaction
merci
voilà pour cette interview de philippe
bas le président de la commission des
lois au micro d'alexandre poussard on va
commencer le débrief de ces questions
d'actualité au gouvernement avec trois
invités sur ce plateau laurence
rossignol bonjour bonjour vous êtes
sénatrice socialiste de l'oise merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous également sur
ce plateau martin lévriers bonjour vous
êtes sénateur la république en marche
des yvelines et enfin jean marie
vanlerenberghe
bonjour au sénateur union centriste du
pas-de-calais rapporteur général de la
commission des affaires sociales alors
philippe a été interrogé à ce sujet à
l'instant le fait est bien que olivier
véran le ministre des solidarités et de
la santé et bien attaque
le sénat est bien autour de du sort en
fait ce qu'il a fait aux projets de loi
se permettant de sortir de l'état
d'urgence sanitaire pour lui c'est aussi
à cause du sénat y bien que tous les
contrôles nécessaires ne peuvent pas
être effet comme il l'aurait voulu
dans les aéroports écoutez et bien la
réponse tout à l'heure du ministre des
solidarités de la santé et on en parle
juste après parmi ces mesures qui ne
sont plus possibles hors de l'état
d'urgence sanitaire il y en a une qui
consisterait à imposer un citoyen
français en france de faire un test pcr
on peut le demander c'est ce que nous
faisons madame la sénatrice pour toutes
les personnes qui viennent des pays dans
lesquels le virus circule nous leur
demandons instamment de présenter les
résultats d'un test négatif est réalisé
dans les 72 heures précédant leur départ
si les personnes n'ont pas réalisé ce
tête
si les personnes n'ont pas réalisé le
test que nous leur demandons pourtant
bien mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
de réaliser dans les 72 heures avant
qu'il quitte le pays d'othe ils sont
originaires et qu'ils arrivent en france
nous leur donnons deux possibilités ou
produire les résultats d'un test négatif
réalisés dans les 48 heures et pour
faciliter la vie des voyageurs nous
avons mis en place nous sommes l'un des
seuls pays à avoir fait des plateformes
de tests pcr au sein même des aéroports
capable d'ores et déjà de faire 2000
tests de par jour gratuit pris en charge
et remboursé par la sécurité sociale
sans quoi nous leur demandons de
respecter et madame la sénatrice mme une
quatorzaine à domicile et nous les
accompagnons dans la réalisation de
cette 14ème voilà olivier ferrand qui
défend la politique du gouvernement
alors qu'il a eu quand même deux
questions sur ce sujet laurence
rossignol
contrôle insuffisant jugent certains
sénateurs dans les aéroports mais
surtout bon il en est venu aussi à
attaquer le sénat et le sort qui l'avait
fait au projet de loi permettant de
sortir de l'état d'urgence sanitaire
c'est moi quand j'écoute aux différents
aux questions au gouvernement je peux
pas oublier ce moment du 28 février je
crois où il était interrogé par mon
collègue bernard jomier sur le début de
l'épidémie et où il a répondu nous
sommes prêts nous sommes prêts pour toi
tout et on a tout ce qu'il faut ne vous
inquiétez pas tout est sous contrôle et
on ne se rappelle ce qui s'est passé
c'est que quinze jours après tout le
monde savait que tout ça n'était
absolument pas prêts etc en fait seuls
les hôpitaux s'étaient préparés seuls
les hôpitaux s'étaient préparés à
accueillir beaucoup de patients en
réanimation mais pour le reste que rien
n'était prêt donc quand j'écoute ville
et veyran je pense toujours à sable donc
en fait j écoute d'une oreille
presque 10 traict voyez vous maintenant
quant au fait de faire porter sur le
sénat la responsabilité de ce que le
gouvernement ne fait pas comment dire on
a continuellement des textes qui vont de
l'assemblée au sénat y du sénat à
l'assemblée
en général ce que le sénat vote est
liquidée par l'assemblée nationale ce
serait bien la première fois qu'un
sommet national nous aurait donné la
main sur un sujet et pas de chance ce
sujet sur lequel le gouvernement se
trouve aujourd'hui en difficulté donc
tout ça c'est de la communication
d'artifice
il n'en restera rien l'été que les
vacances arrivent relation par l'inter
se finit de tous ces propos ne restera
rien dans quelques semaines il ne
restera rien de tout cela martin révélé
bon pourtant vous vous plongez bien sûr
la commission ad' enquête sur la queue
vie de 19 actuellement
c'est en quelque chose tout à fait vrai
mais on n'a pas en cours et attaquer le
sujet des aéroports dont nous parlions
tout à l'heure par le biais du ministre
vers ans le co vide n'est pas en
vacances et combien même on est une
oreille discrète distraite ou qui
s'accrochent ce qu'on a pu entendre au
tout début d'une crise où je rappelle
qu'il a été ministre depuis quinze jours
je dis attention les français
ont besoin d'une écoute et d'une parole
politique forte
sans ces courageuses et qui rappelle
qu'on est en crise et on ne peut pas
dire comme ça ça n'est pas très grave ce
que dit le ministre toute façon ça
passera la maladie est là où elle n'est
pas là la maladie et la lame et 10 pour
revenir ce qui se passe dans les
aéroports est un sujet aussi je pense
que le ministre vers ans a voulu dire
dans ses propos n'ont pas que c'était de
la faute du législateur ou du sénat mais
que le sénat devant le sénat a pris une
position il demande au sénat de prendre
acte de sa position après de fait je
rejoins ma collègue laurence rossignol
de dire si l'assemblée nationale avait
voulu le rétablira le pouvez le faire
aussi mais on doit aussi nous sénat
prendre acte de ce qu'on fait parce
qu'au moment où on le fait on pense que
c'est bien aussi je ne crois pas je
crois que dans cette situation on est
tous on a tous cette volonté de sortir
les français de cette crise sanitaire
qui est une crise économique aussi et
donc on essaye chacun comme on peut de
la meilleure façon possible que l'on
croit avoir à ce moment là de faire des
choses il peut y avoir des désaccords il
peut y avoir des erreurs mais attention
disons français d'être prudent et c'est
ce qui me paraît le plus important et
même aux aéroports oui s'il ya un
désaccord profond entre le sénat et
l'assemblée nationale jean marie
vanlerenberghe
effectivement et bien l'assemblée
nationale a tout le loisir de pouvoir
modifier le texte pour finir à le a le
dernier mot dont qu'avez-vous pensez
vous de la réponse de quoi on va le voir
ce soir puisqu'on va
je dirais tirer les conclusions d'une
cmp non conclusives sur la dette sociale
p l'autonomie c'est le texte qui va
passer là ce soir
en soirée donc c'est mal assemblé assuré
a le dernier mot et parfois on le
regrette
là on nous fait un procès moi je crois
que le problème n'est pas là moi je mets
pas en doute la parole de l'hiver
absolument pas et quand il a parlé en
février que tout était prêt je pense
qu'il le croyait sincèrement parce qu'il
arrivait au ministère et qu'on lui avait
dit tout est bouclé tout va bien et que
la doctrine c'est ya pas besoin de
masques doctrine propagée par les
nombreux médecins virologues que j'ai pu
et puis des mots l'homme que ce que j'ai
vu sur toutes les chaînes de télévision
le vrai problème aujourd'hui pour les
masques ou pour les tests et notamment
dans les aéroports
c est ce que la politique qui a été
votée à l'assemblée comme au sénat
la politique qui est soutenu par le
gouvernement est appliquée banon à
l'évidence on voit on voit sur les
chaînes de télévision des gens qui
arrivent effectivement les mains dans
les pôles dubaï a pas de test ici en
arrivant là à paris l aéroport etc
c'est une contre communication par
rapport à ce que annonce je crois avec
beaucoup de sincérité le ministre donc
le problème un problème de coordination
entre le ministère des transports
ministère de les affaires étrangères
ministère de l'intérieur et le ministère
de la santé
donc je dirais à olivier ferrand essayer
de voir au niveau interministériel si
tout est bien calme tout est bien en or
d'écouté bien appliquée oui oui alors à
pagnol moi je partage ce que viennent
dire bien d'être les deux collègues un
sur le fait que le coc ville n'est pas
en vacances je reprends l'expression
d'un lévrier
c'est vrai et que il faut des consignes
fermes d'ailleurs on a quand même était
tous un peu surpris sur la manière dont
les masques sont devenus obligatoires
dans les lieux publics
d'abord dans le premier round d'abord au
premier annoncé 14 juillet pour le 1er
août
vous avez pourquoi le premier route et
puis en fin de compte datar est avancée
au milieu bref c'est plutôt une bonne
chose
tout le monde était d'accord tout le
monde était d'accord et nous mêmes leur
nez sur lui la tour n'a pas de masque on
nous a posé pour rentrer sur le plateau
et on les remet en sortant et on les
porte dans l'hémicycle
et partout donc bien sûr c'est sérieux
peut-être olivier ferrand dit ce qu'il
croit être est ce que je réagis tout à
l'heure sur et alors on a deux mille
tests on teste 2000 personnes par jour
et nous sommes le seul pays au monde à
faire ça et c'est là où je me dis ça me
rappelle quand même ce discours tout le
temps d'abord à la dent on jamais
personne n'a fait avant nous ce qu'on
fait et aucun personne aucune au cas
l'ex intérieur ne fais une chose que ce
qu'on fait c'est ce discours un peu
fanfaron en permanence qui n'est pas de
mise et il aurait mieux fait de dire
comme vient de le dire jean marie
vanlerenberghe
ils auraient mieux fait dire
effectivement je suis d'accord on a un
problème ce qu'on dit n'est pas
appliquée comment ça se fait j'en parle
avec mes collègues et ça le sera
voilà ce gouvernement on perd les coûts
pourquoi on notre capacité à l'écouté
baisse parce que jamais on a
l'impression que les problèmes qu'on
leur pose
il les voit jamais on a l'impression
qu'ils prennent en compte les problèmes
tout le temps il dit en réponse à tout
donc au bout d'un moment réponse à tout
on n'écoute plus vaut mieux dire
franchement quand on a des problèmes
c'est comme pour les basques au début tu
aurais dit voilà on n'a pas de masque et
donc on va les réserves et à tell tale
et activités telle profession et telles
circonstances
en attendant d'en avoir eh bien les
français meneur excepté les français
auraient compris et alors qu'aujourd'hui
on vit quand même avec sur les masques
je finis juste là dessus avec un un
dossier qui a été mal ouvert et puis des
représentations que les français sans
fond qui sont le produit de discours
successifs différents et contradictoires
et donc les gens savent plus trop croire
sur les masques mais bon aujourd'hui
encore ils ont compris
l'auguste l'emporter mais on va parler
puisque effectivement les masculins en a
été question lors de cette séance de
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
ils ont été rendus obligatoires dans les
lieux publics clos lundi et le ministre
des solidarités de la santé toujours lui
olivier ferrand a également été
questionné là dessus et notamment le
groupe communiste qui lui a demandé bien
la gratuité des masques écoutez sa
réponse
ce masque la coûte 1 euro il est lavable
et réutilisable jusqu'à 30 fois
admettons vous utilisiez trois masques
par jour et que vous ayez besoin 30
jours de porter un masque et vous que
vous êtes 4 j'arrive à un calcul qui est
plus proche des 15
au 20 euros à la rigueur si on inclut
les week-ends que des 220 euros
cela étant ça notre sa note pas sa note
pas madame la sénatrice la priorité que
vous portez au fait que les plus
fragiles puissent être protégés et qui
n'est pas d'obstacle financier
croyez moi comme ministre de la science
de la santé mais aussi des solidarités
je fais il y aurait personnellement à ce
que personne ne soit en impossibilité de
porter un masque
compte tenu d'un obstacle financier je
crois que c'est essentiel et nous
pourrons nous retrouver autour de cet
objectif
martin vrille et bien l'argument du
ministre c'est que c'est moins cher que
ce que l'on revient l'entendent mais
c'est tout de même un coût que de rendre
et bien c'est masque obligatoire dans
les lieux publics clos alors vous et la
gravité vous avez tout dit ça n'est pas
le coût annoncé on pourra toujours
ergoter sur les discussions de prix mais
ça a un coût c'est un coût et il n'y a
pas d'égalité devant le cour pour tous
les français en revanche pas oublier
quand même que toutes les entreprises se
doivent de fournir des masques à tous
leurs salariés
tous les indépendants tout le monde donc
le les masques qu'on doit avoir dans le
privé ne correspondent pas non plus à
quatre masques par jour ou 5 max par
jour donc il me paraît essentiel et
c'est ce qu'a dit ministre je le rejoins
complètement qu'on se doit de s'occuper
de la précarité
c'est une mesure sociale n'est pas une
mesure médicale je redis aussi le masque
n'est pas un médicament il faut faire
très attention à ça donc
donc ça relève du ccs il me semble et sa
relève effectivement de la précarité et
on se doit d'aider les plus précaires à
porter un masque pour les protéger puis
aussi pour protéger les autres c'est
suffisant jean-marie waldhambach d'aider
les plus précaires comme le coût que
cela peut représenter et qui est non
négligeable
est ce que vous comprenez ce qui demande
la gratuité des masques c'est aussi une
raison de sécurité sanitaire publié je
pense que la réponse de martin lévriers
comme celle du ministre me paraît ce
tout à fait justifié ce qu'il faut c'est
demandé que tout le monde puisse porter
des masques
celui qui n'a pas les moyens de
l'acheter
on doit l'aider c'est tout c'est tout
aussi simple que ça et je pense que les
ccas aujourd'hui d'ailleurs remplissent
largement cette fonction dans son final
oui si on dit les ccas alors je partage
l'idée que y'a pas de raison que ce soit
gratuit pour tout le monde il ya des
gens qui peuvent tout à fait payer leur
masse qui faisait face voilà il ya une
partie de la population pour qui 15
euros
ça compte toujours dans le mois 15 euros
c'est important alors laissez ça et ça
veut dire que c'est des collectivités
assez des communes qui vont payer et
puis ça veut dire qu'il faut avoir assez
serré ce prêt vous à proximité vous
savez comme moi sont de petites communes
il n'ya pas y'a pas forcément le produit
je pense que ce serait bien que dans les
caf ont les caisses d'allocations
familiales ou là on a une grande partie
comme la population précaire et en
particulier les familles monoparentales
et tous les allocataires dont serait
exclu
voilà donc dans les caf jaurès qu'il va
y avoir un lots attribués
systématiquement je sais pas si c'est
comme ça dans toutes les caf j'ai passé
pour vérifier des véritables difficultés
alors justement kenney alors moi j'avais
utilisé masque on a aussi beaucoup parlé
j'ai fait que les gens utilisent
honnêtement je n'ai pas entendu un
certain en revanche que j'ai tendu est
ce que j'ai entendu qu'il me remonte du
terrain et j'aurais voulu
on n'a pas le temps de poser toutes les
questions qu'on veut mais interrogé le
gouvernement là dessus c'est des parents
qui m'ont saisi qui sont des parents
d'enfants atteints de troubles
envahissants du développement ou des
enfants y ont des handicaps mentaux et
qui n'arrivent pas à faire porter le
masque à leurs enfants
et là on en est là et qu'ils prennent
des amendes et déjà pendant le
confinement il m'était revenus des
histoires d'amande qui était franchement
pas justifié et abusive
là il se serait bien quand même que pour
les parents qui à coups qu'ils sont
obligés de sortir avec leurs enfants ils
peuvent pas les laisser à la maison il
pouvait des courses avec excès proxeo 11
ans l'âge à partir duquel le masque est
obligatoire et il ya des enfants pour
qui cet insupportable un enfant un
enfant atteint d'autisme
ça peut être insupportable pour y porter
un masque c'est pas normal que ces
parents là et des amendes
voilà il faut quand même que les skull
efforts de la suisse ce gendarme de
police un certificat médical
pour ne pas le porter la preuve que
c'est pas si facile que ça sans rien d'y
aller chez le médecin
c'était mon que les forces que les
forces de police ou une carte d'une
carte de handicapé tu vois là mais il
faut quand même que des consignes qu'ils
soient donnés pour être compréhensif à
l'égard des parents pour qui c'est plus
difficile que pour d'autres aussi
on va continuer à parler et bien de la
crise de l'aco vide avec vous à
alexandre puisque vous êtes avec
catherine frot cassia salle des
conférences catherine professeur qui a
tout à l'heure interpellé le
gouvernement autour et bien de la
sécurité sanitaire dans les aéroports
effectivement terme car catherine pons
cassia vous avez interrogé le ministre
la santé olivier ferrand sur ce que
certains appellent et bien des passoires
aco vite dans les aéroports est-ce que
vous avez été convaincu par la réponse
du ministre qui notamment met en cause
le sénat qu'ils auraient désarmé au
niveau législatif pour contrôler
virologiquement les ressortissants des
pays étrangers
j'avoue que j'ai été un peu surprise de
cette réponse il faisait référence au
texte qui devait prolonger l'état
d'urgence sanitaire
mais on peut par
des crêpes un arrêté décidé un certain
nombre de mesures on n'a pas besoin de
mettre en place des textes de loi en
plus l'état d'urgence sanitaire
il n'était pas prévue de durer le
gouvernement nous a jamais demandé de le
prolonger advitam eternam pour prendre
toutes ces mesures
donc là c'est une recrue c'est une
réponse qui est faite parce que il
constate que les français sont
mécontentes de savoir que bien des
étrangers mais alors je parle des
nationaux mais ça peut être aussi par
bateau ça peut être aussi par train qui
n'a pas vraiment de contrôle aux
frontières et tous les personnes qui me
disent être arrivés je parlais des
aéroports dont l'aéroport de nice mais
ya rien on ne demande rien et en plus on
fait la queue pendant une heure ou une
heure et demie les uns contre les autres
avec des vols qui arrivent de pays
différents y compris de pays qui sont en
zone rouge sans aucune sans aucun
contrôle et on sait bien qu'un bon
nombre de personnes peuvent être
asymptomatique
donc c'est pas la prise de température
que lancent certains aéroports
c'est j'ai vu effectivement cette prise
dans les aéroports mais la plupart ne
s'arrête pas y a rien d'obligatoire en
france et tant qu'il y aura rien
obligatoire en france alors là c'est
passé des français qui reviennent c'est
des binationaux qui revient mais là je
disais une interview des hospices de
lyon qui disait qu'il y avait un avion
dans lesquels qui arrivait d'algérie
dans lesquelles plusieurs personnes
étaient déjà malades dont qui ont
contaminé l'avion il n'y a pas eu de
suivi et d'autres personnes de
l'entourage qui ne présentait aucun
symptôme mais qui avait le vide donc
aussi on si on ne met rien en place
c'est grave et l'algérie est en zone
verte
pourquoi il ya deux pays d'afrique qui
sont en zone des vertes alors qu'il ya
toujours autant de coville
on peut quand même s'interroger par
rapport à ce type de décision il ya la
question des moyens humains également
puisque olivier verront disait pour
contrôler les 35 mille passagers qui
arrivent à roissy par jour il faut 1200
personnes
l'escale gouvernement mais assez de
moyens humains on peux pas faut pas non
plus critiquer les gouvernements pour le
critiquer on peut pas tester tout le
monde mais il ya des moyens de mise en
place un certain nombre de pays il
réfute mais un certain nombre de pays
demandent que l'on transmette par l'as
vence par internet des certificats dans
les pays où il n'y a pas de certificat
qui est au moins des informations sûres
je m'appelle je réside je vais résider
là est inscrit pour qu'on puisse les
suivre et ça mettre en place un système
informatique de déclarations excusez moi
le masque tombe
quand on parle c'est pas compliqué il ya
quand même énormément de pays dans
lequel on ne peut aller qu'en demandant
des visas par internet et ajouter une ou
deux questions de ce style est en tout
cas mettre en place suivi ce que je
reproche au gouvernement c'est qu'il
n'ya pas de suivi
si la personne ne veut pas dire j'ai de
la fièvre ou refusent de prendre la
température et ne dit pas où elle va
mais il n'y a rien et l'épidémie risque
de repartir peut-être une progression
pour conclure rapidement est-ce que vous
avez le sentiment qu'on est prêt à
affronter la deuxième vague j'espère
qu'il n'y aura pas de deuxième bague je
pense que les hôpitaux et les français
sont un peu plus prêts à accepter un
certain nombre de contraintes
mais
une deuxième vague ce sera une
catastrophe économique et sociale plus
importante qu'une catastrophe sanitaire
avant la vie effectivement merci
beaucoup catherine pocatiere d'avoir
répondu à mes questions
merci beaucoup alexandre pour cette
nouvelle interview on va parler aussi
bien une autre conséquence de la crise
de la copie de la conséquence est bien
c'est là le stinger de la santé laurence
rossignol nous sommes au lendemain du
ségur de la santé d'un certain nombre
d'annoncés d'olivier verrons à ce que
vous jugez les avancées suffisante alors
il ya eu une enveloppe de plus de 8
milliards d'euros pour l'augmentation
des salaires 50 millions d'euros pour
créer 4000 lits à la demande une
gouvernance revue avec plus de place
notamment au local est ce que ça ce sont
des avancées vous saluer oui oui mais
sur le secteur de la santé je trouve que
c'est beaucoup d'argent nécessaire oui
pour un faible engagement politique d'un
certain point de vue en fait avant avant
le changement de gouvernement on était
parti sur la santé 2022 c'est comme ça
que oui le plan douanier suisse le temps
ubs luzin santé 2022
québec qui travaillaient quelque avec
avec comme objet de réfléchir réellement
à l'organisation du système de santé
le plan de ma santé 2022 a été
visiblement mis de côté c'est plus lui
qui a servi de base au grenelle de la
santé par ou du moins s'est passé parce
qu'elle sort sais pas ce qui ressort
l'argent est là mais qu'est ce qu'il en
est exactement de l'avenir du système de
santé indépendamment des augmentations
indispensable pour les personnels
soignants
donc j'ai un peu perplexe sur ceux sur
les restes osseux grenade la santé tant
mieux pour les salles
tant mieux pour les personnels des
hôpitaux ont eu une augmentation de
salaire qui était nécessaire et
justifiée pour le reste j'attends de
voir comment toutes ces histoires de
gouvernance avons réellement se mettre
en place parce que y'a pas le process
collectif démocratique de concertation
interne qui pourrait nous faire voir un
pouce havas dont je réserve mon jugement
sur cette affaire
pourtant quelques mois des efforts
reconnus mais encore beaucoup
d'interrogations
martin lévriers c'est bien oui mais
c'est
rappelons le 50 jours pour faire un tel
de telles propositions
leur petite différence dans le cadre de
ma santé 2022 et qu'on appuie sur masson
on s'appuie pardon sont marrantes et
2022 pour accélérer un certain nombre de
commencer comme ça c'est loin pas assez
vite
ça fait 40 ans qu'on est en crise dans
l'hôpital donc ça fait 40 ans qu'on
n'allait pas assez vite ou qu'on allait
trop lentement on est tous responsables
il faut je crois que là il ya un moment
il faut regarder les choses en face
c'est pas la peine de dire truc machin
on est tous responsables de ce qui s'est
passé
oui il fallait aux balises revaloriser
les salaires oui c'était urgent oui
l'hôpital est passé au bord d'une
catastrophe will personnel hospitalier a
été extraordinaire dans sa façon
d'appréhender la difficulté et oui il
fallait un vrai coup d'accélérateur sur
les réformes pour remettre sur les rails
un système qui qui qui battait de
l'halloween est ce que c'est une réponse
à la hauteur de la crise sur le plan des
soignants sans conteste je pense que 8
milliards directement rapidement
c'était attendu mais là cet effectif et
c'est donc on ne peut que saluer cet
effort qui est considérable il reste
d'autres sujets on a évoqué notamment en
cours enfin le ministre a présenté
modification de la gouvernance des
hôpitaux ce très important
moi j'ai pas le sentiment qu'il ya
changement profond on va dit on dit au
médecin
vous avez le pouvoir si vous le prenez
ils ont actuellement mais personne ne le
rappelle ça il ya un directeur
mais il ya un directoire il est
président d'un directoire et d'un
directoire sur 7 il ya quatre médecins
le problème c'est que les médecins se
n'êtes pas d'accord entre eux et
j'attends de voir effectivement
l'application pour voir si la
gouvernance fonctionne mieux
certes le directeur pouvait nommer chef
de paul qui voulait dans l'hôpital là il
y aura une réalité tout directeur un peu
manager
intelligent bas il progresse concertée
ils prenaient contact pour savoir quel
était celui qui avait qui était adoubé
par ses pairs bon j'attends de voir si
c'est une modification profonde et
salutaire par contre il ya un point sur
lequel j'ai pas beaucoup d'informations
c'est l'accès aux soins
c'était très très présent je dirais
l'accès aux soins et territoriaux la
relation ville hôpital
ça c'est très très important et médecins
de ville ont été bouclées localement
qu'est ce qui est aujourd'hui l'hôpital
c'est l'état qui en est le propriétaire
on l'a vu justement à une et 13
milliards de transferts de la dette
hospitalière que nous refusons parce que
c'est à l'état de le couvrir
mais est ce qui serait pas normal par
exemple de transférer les hôpitaux à
l'assurance maladie l'assurance maladie
qui finalement fourni l'argent pour la
gestion de l'hôpital
donc je crois que il ya un certain
nombre de points sur lesquels moi
j'aimerais bien débattre avec le
ministre sur ce seigneur encore voir si
je n'étais pas juste un oui martin
léveillé sur la question des ehpad 2
milliards sur cinq ans pour rénover et
transformer les ehpad est ce que c'est à
la hauteur on sait que la commission
d'enquêté naturelles notamment va
beaucoup s'interroger et bien sûr les
ehpad le scandale des ehpad dit alain
milon dans la crise du président
je n'aime pas le mot scandale les ehpad
et est gérée d'une certaine façon avec
des obligations en particulier de
transmission d'informations aux ars qui
était ce qu'elle est et ils ont fait ce
qu'ils avaient à faire à l'époque
c'était parce qu'il fallait face à une
telle ou telle pandémie n'oublions pas
que c'est une pandémie et que si on a
bien su gérer une pandémie on serait
tous gérés
on est toujours surpris par une pandémie
oui 2 milliards c'est déjà un bon début
est ce que ça sera suffisant je ne pense
pas parce que la population française
vieillit et que donc on devra avancer
très toujours sur ce sujet là un gros
effort à faire sur les ehpad et sur la
prise en charge de la dépendance de
façon
le grand jeu mignard attendu 2 milliards
pour répondre aux difficultés des ehpad
il ya des sujets il ya beaucoup de
sujets dans le sujet il ya le reste à
charge pour les familles est-ce que ça a
à voir avec ces 2 milliards j'en suis
pas si sûr il ya les toons voilà je suis
là
la modernisation ou d'annulation vous
avez vous savez il ya des ehpad moi j'ai
végéter en responsabilité sur ce sujet
j'ai visité plus des pâtes que vous
trois réunis probablement pas sans s'en
remettre en cause votre intérêt pour le
sujet mais à raison de trois par ce à
raison de trois par semaine au départ il
ya beaucoup dépend en dons dans lequel
le bâti et l'aménagement est en bon état
qui sont relativement récents le secteur
privé est venu c'est un formidable
investissement les ehpad faut quand même
pas oublier que la rentabilité
financière des actions dans les pattes
dans les ehpad l'investissement des
actionnaires est une des plus élevées de
tout le secteur financier donc il ya du
bâti ses propres mais ils appâtent alors
le personnel les filles font tous
c'est-à-dire qu'elles font le ménage les
toilettes
le repas et l'animation dont on a un
énorme problème dans les ehpad de
travail de répartition du travail de
nombre de personnels d'animation de
prise en charge est ce que tout ça est
couvert dans les deux milliards j'en ai
pas la moindre idée et je voudrais voir
et c'est pas que des poèmes de
d'investissement dans le bâti et dont on
a d'abord des preuves de fonctionnement
humain les repas vous avez déjà regardé
un plateau d pad
non mais franchement regardez ce que
j'ai fait c'est pas étonnant que les
personnes âgées
sauf de manioc de maigri c'est
immangeable
et en plus on règle le problème quand on
a passé deux semaines suivant les
époques
moi j'ai vu des cuisiniers qui m'ont dit
j'ai rendu mon tablier parce qu'on m'a
demandé de descendre le prix du repas un
coût tels que j'y suis pas arrivé dans
les bacs le mur or on paie toujours ce
même sujet de la gestion avancée mais
voilà et adopte elle aussi alors
si les ehpad sont faits pour être
rentable ça peut pas être con et ça ne
peut pas être compatible avec une
bientraitance des personnes qui sont en
même temps je veux dire aux gens n'ayez
pas peur quand vos parents ou grands
parents sont allés pas de l'info n'est
pas de penser par pour autant qu'on les
a mis dans un lieu de torture c'est pas
ça mais on pourrait faire tellement
mieux juste le mot de la fin là dessus
on savait sujet le sujet de la
dépendance une est ouvert puisque le
gouvernement justement va en débattre
encore ce soir dans l'hémicycle sénat
ont créé la cinquième branche
oui le problème c'est moi je suis
totalement d'accord évidemment vous
aussi je crois que tout le monde est
d'accord tôt pour dire on y va on y va
mais les moyens et qu'est ce qu'on va
faire les gens ce qu'ils souhaitent
c'est rester à domicile en priorité donc
les ehpad
il faut replacer cela dans un plan
d'ensemble de l'aide à domicile jusqu'à
la grande dépendance viron nous pour
effectivement placé nos parents nos
grands parents dans les ehpad et je
pense que les moyens qui sont mis là
sont encore insuffisants mais le mans
est lancé le mouvement est lancé et ça
n'était pas le seul élan c'est
l'occasion d'en débattre en plfss
nouveau
rejoindre alexandre touzard salle des
conférences car vous êtes avec marlène
schiappa à la ministre déléguée à la
citoyenneté on vous écoute
oui avec marlène schiappa pour parler de
son nouveau ministre ministère délégué à
la citoyenneté vous avez déclaré ce
matin que vous serez la ministre qui va
porter la laïcité
et ça tombe bien les sénateurs
travaillent sur ce sujet et il dénonce
notamment et bien l'omniprésence de
l'islam radical dans certains quartiers
est ce que vous êtes d'accord avec ce
diagnostic
d'abord effectivement je suis ministre
délégué chargé de la citoyenneté et
notamment j'entends porter les valeurs
de la république parmi lesquels le
principe de laïcité qui est fondamental
pourquoi parce que la laïcité c'est un
bouclier qui nous permet à vous et moi
par exemple d'être considérés comme des
citoyens indifféremment de notre
religion
je ne connais pas vous appartenance
religieuse ou non vous ne connaissez pas
les miennes et les gens qui nous
regardent non pas à les connaître
parce que c'est du domaine de la sphère
privée et ça ça nous permet d'être
considérés comme des citoyens et c'est
important
ensuite les sénateurs ont mené un
travail auquel vous faites référence est
un rapport notamment
on va bien sûr il travaille avec le
ministre de l'intérieur puisque nous
préparons un projet de loi de lutte
contre les séparatismes et nous
entendons y travailler avec l'ensemble
des parlementaires qu'il s'agisse des
sénateurs lr qui siège en ce moment et
qui ont travaillé sur ce rapport ou des
sénateurs et des députés
d'autres bords politiques notamment bien
sûr de la majorité mais également de
l'opposition vous êtes d'accord avec le
diagnostic il ya un problème de laïcité
dans certains quartiers alors moi je
crois que la laïcité n'est pas assez
défendu et ça je les dis de longue date
ça fait des années que je bataille pour
que la laïcité soit au coeur des débats
politiques que nous menons j'ai coécrit
un livre qu'il avait la laïcité points
pour défendre ce principe de laïcité
nous avons organisé à la république en
marge des débats est d'ailleurs à cette
occasion il y avait une étude ifop
fondation jean jaurès qui montrait que
plus de 70% des français considéraient
que la laïcité n'était pas assez défendu
par les responsables politiques
donc quand le premier ministre jean
castex s'exprime dans sa première
interview de premier ministre en disant
moi ce qui me définit ce sont les
valeurs de la république et c'est
notamment la défense du principe de
laïcité
eh bien je crois que c'est un message
très fort qu'il adresse au pays et sur
l'islam radical vous allez le combattre
bien sûr la lutte contre le séparatisme
c'est aussi évidemment une lutte contre
le séparatisme islamistes d'ailleurs le
gouvernement a d'ores et déjà fait
fermer près de 300 endroits
problématiques depuis le début du
quinquennat je pense à des débits de
boissons je pense à des écoles qui
prêchait justement ce séparatisme et que
les précédents gouvernements avec gérard
collomb et ensuite à christophe castaner
ont fait fermer justement pour lutter
contre le séparatisme et je crois qu'il
faut maintenant continuer et amplifier
cette action est ce que vous serez
toujours la ministre qui luttera contre
eux les violences faites aux femmes
je crois que quand on est féministe
depuis l'adolescence comme c'est mon cas
et j'ai maintenant 37 ans et je suis
mère de famille et merde adolescente moi
même on n'arrête pas d'être féministe
heureusement dans le pays il ya beaucoup
de féministes et pas seulement la
ministre chargée d'égalité femmes-hommes
donc je crois que ce gouvernement
il porte la grande cause du quinquennat
pour l'égalité femmes hommes cela mise
de l'égalité femmes hommes
bien évidemment mais aussi par exemple
la ministre des sports qui mène un
combat courageux contre les violences
sexuelles dans le spa agnès pannier rue
nash et la mise de l'industrie qui se
bat pour la place des femmes dans ce
secteur habituellement plutôt masculin
et en ce qui me concerne j'ai la
responsabilité au ministère de
l'intérieur de l'engagement des forces
de l'ordre dans la protection des femmes
vous savez que partout les forces de
l'ordre sont en première ligne pour
protéger les femmes face aux violences
intrafamiliales face au harcèlement de
rue face aux violences sexuelles et cet
engagement des 290 1000 personnes du
ministère de l'intérieur
je veux le porter et l'incarné bien sûr
avec gérald darmanin dernière question
mais n'échappe à qui concerne votre
ministre de tutelle gérald darmanin
au delà de l enquête pour viol qu'est ce
que vous pensez
sur le fait qu'un homme échange des
passes trop des passe-droits contre des
faveurs sexuelles c'est ce qu'a reconnu
gérald darmanin et ses avocats alors
d'abord moi il me semble que j'ai vu
passer hier un communiqué de ses avocats
qui disait au contraire qui n'avait pas
connu cela
mais en tout cas moi j'observe qu'il y a
eu ni et cette ligne c'est la justice
d'ailleurs est ce qu'il y à un moment
quelqu'un qui est coupable ou innocent
la justice a rendu de non lieu un
classement sans suite je crois qu
ensuite le reste et les commentaires sur
fantasme ou la vie réelle ou supposée
personnelle intime de chacun je crois
qu'on a vue dernièrement à quel point ça
ne servait pas le débat public ce que je
peux vous garantir c'est que moi je veux
que 100 % des femmes puissent déposer
plainte quand elles ont été victimes de
violences quelles que soient ses
audiences que c'est plein depuis cette
reprise qu'ils puissent être qualifiés
qu'elles puissent être transmises et
qu'ensuite la justice puisse passer et
ça c'est l'engagement que je porte au
ministère de l'intérieur
très bien merci beaucoup magnifique
chapelle d'avoir répondu à mes questions
allaient nous il reste juste quelques
minutes pour parler de ce sujet mais
laurent sonia je vous fait réagir car on
a besoin de ces la réponse à vous la
question vous posiez la semaine dernière
puisque vous jugiez que le problème
n'était pas la présomption d'innocence
mais aussi le problème le fait que
gérald darmanin il reconnu avoir échangé
des faveurs sexuelles contre contre
voilà deux en l'occurrence hlm
aujourd'hui ce qui est factuel c'est que
dans les deux affaires dans l'es2 plane
qui ont été déposées contre le ministre
de l'intérieur il est admis nîmes a
reconnu par ministre de l'intérieur et
ses avocats qu'il ya bien eu des
relations sexuelles avec ces femmes qui
étaient venus lui demander une
intervention déjà ça me paraît être un
problème suffisant
quant à bahreïn cheikh pas je ne vois
pas comment il peut tout à la fois
expliqué qu'elle défend les violences
faites aux femmes est qualifié de
fantasmes ce que les femmes qui sont
venues porter plainte ont décrit en fait
elle fait comme les hommes et le
patriarcat a fait pendant des années où
commence par salir la victime l'a
traitée de menteuse parce que si c'est
un fantasme c'est un mensonge et dire
ensuite que l'on soutient son ministre
de l'intérieur
donc je commenterai pas plus que ça ça
me parait son discours me par est avant
tout un discours qui est d'ailleurs sa
fonction elles et la caution de gérard
damanan des parts dans un gouvernement
elle est là pour dire moi qui étais
féminisme moi qui suis féministe je n'ai
aucun problème à travailler que jardin
mana elles et la caution de gérard
darmanin et donc elle en arrive à dire
des choses qui nuisent à ce une cause
qu'elle a probablement défendu
sincèrement auparavant c'est à dire elle
contribue à disqualifier des paroles des
victimes et ce n'est pas une affaire de
présomption d'innocence
les faits sont avérés et la question de
la présomption d'innocence concerne la
qualification pénale des faits voilà
est-ce que c'est un viol ou pas en tout
cas en ce qui concerne
son sexuelles avec des gens qui viennent
dans nos bureaux nous demander des
interventions on est trois
parlementaires on en a beaucoup
il ya plusieurs façons de faire et à
ceux qui prennent de l'argent
c'est honteux il ya ceux qui prennent
des avantages en nature
c'est honteux et il ya ceux qui prennent
des relations sexuelles c'est honteux
aussi voilà après marianne qui a passé
son problème et sa colère dans tout ce
qu'ils prennent rien oui qui sont les
plus traitées honteux et le plus grand
nombre nous apprennent rien ne demandons
rien surtout voilà on ne demande rien
que vous réagissez ce débat qui continue
alors je connais pas de l'intérieur je
ne connais pas le dossier de la justice
donc je ne peux pas dire c'est factuel
ça ne l'est pas je suis désolé donc
visiblement c'est beaucoup plus que moi
moi je ne sais pas c'est factuel ou pas
je dis oui mais ça c'est autre chose
c'est à la justice de dire si cette et
factuelle ou pas c'est pas moi c'est pas
vrai c'est pas nous parlementaires moi
je prends acte de ça donc je ne porte
pas de jugement cette affaire là en
revanche je suis désolée la présomption
d'innocence est un autre sujet aussi et
celui là mais c'est pas pour gérald
darmanin c'est pour tout le monde je
l'avais déjà dit pour pour fillon à
l'époque en 2017 on n'a pas attaqué des
gens parce que quelqu'un a dit quelque
chose on doit attendre que la justice se
prononce sur des faits ou pas et là on
est en droit de dire c'est pas bien mais
aujourd'hui je n'ai aucune réponse si ce
n'est sur l'appréhension d'innocence en
disant désolé on doit tous protéger nos
concitoyens par la présence sur
l'innocence
le mot de la fin jean marie van haaren
da sur cette affaire qui n'en finit pas
et bien de faire parler après le
remaniement du gouvernement donc on ne
peut qu'être d'accord avec ce que dit
martin lévriers je pense que il est
difficile de nous ne se soustraient pas
là juste ans gérald darmanin parce qu'il
est ministre il sera jugé parce qu'il
est un homme et que il a semble-t-il je
sais pas s'il a reconnu moi j'ai pas
entendu ça s'il a reconnu qu'il avait
effectivement eu des relations sexuelles
oui consenties at-il dire tu dit sitôt
fait que cette taxe
question en matière de violences
sexuelles le débat est toujours sur le
consensus
alors pour moi no coment sur des
questions qui relèvent de la justice et
je crois que la justice se devra la
manche et le plus vite sera le mieux
d'ailleurs
évidemment il ne s'est pas soustrait à
la justice c'est vrai mais ça posera un
problème ressemble un conflit d'intérêts
que le ministre de l'intérieur soit
l'objet d'une enquête préliminaire
et qui va être enquêter par des
fonctionnaires qui sont sous ses ordres
c'est un petit problème on ne
l'accepterai sur aucun autre sujet et
dans un cadre le ministère vaste débat
merci à tous les trois d'avoir participé
à ce dernier des briques des questions
d'actualité au gouvernement de la saison
à très bonne soirée sur public sénat
[Musique]